चलो एक बार मैं चेक कर लेता हूं जल्दी से
आ जाओ सभी लोग आ जाओ फटाफट आ जाओ फटाफट आ
जाओ सभी लोग सभी लोग आ जाओ फटाफट आ
जाओ आ रहे सभी लोग बढ़िया हे गाइस गुड
इवनिंग
सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है सबको गाइस ऑडिबल
विजिबल क्लियर सब कुछ क्लियर है बता दीजिए
जल्दी से एक
बार जल्दी बता दीजिए जल्दी फटाफट बताइए
फटाफट बताइए सभी लोग आ जाइए सभी लोग जल्दी
बताइए हां तो मैं यहां पे चेक कर पा रहा
हूं मेरी ऑडियो
शायद सही
है हां जी अब बता दीजिए जल्दी से ऑडियो
वीडियो सब ओके है ना मस्त है ना परफेक्ट
है ना कोई प्रॉब्लम तो नहीं है जल्दी से
बता
दीजिए
फटाफट ओ
बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया सभी
को आ जाने देते हैं एक बार सभी को आ जाने
देते
हैं सभी को आ जाने देते
हैं वी आर वेटिंग फॉर एवरीवन टू
जॉइन चलो काफी लोग आ चुके हैं यहां
पे सर आप आपको बगड़ी लैंग्वेज आती है
बगड़ी लैंग्वेज कौन सी लैंग्वेज है यार
मुझे नहीं
पता सर यू हैव मेड द ग्रुप इन विच वी कैन
शेयर एंड चैट वो ग्रुप फुल हां फुल अभी जो
इस वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको लिंक
मिलेगा ना उसको जवाइन कर लो उसको जवाइन कर
लो वहां पर ग्रुप फुल नहीं हुआ है ठीक है
आई एम गुड आई एम गुड ब्रदर आई एम
गुड तो कैसा चल रहा है आपका आपका बग बाउंट
का जो आपकी जो ट क्लासेस अभी चल रही है तो
आपकी बग बाउंटीज की जर्नी कैसी चल रही है
आप लोग मुझे बताइए जल्दी से एक बार एक बार
सभी लोग बता दीजिए कैसी चल रही है आप लोग
हंट वगैरह कर रहे हैं रियल टाइम में मतलब
क्लासेस के बाद टाइम दे पा रहे हैं या
नहीं दे पा रहे कर रहे हैं हंट या नहीं कर
रहे हैं और अगर कर रहे हैं तो फिर कुछ पता
क्यों नहीं चल रहा क्यों इतनी शांति टाइप
लग रही है
मुझे सर पीएचपी वर्जन से हमसे इंस्टॉल
नहीं हुआ
ये तो गलत बात है कि
youtube's हॉल ऑफ फेम नासा में निकाला है
थैंक यू सो मच सर वेलकम कपिल एंड मेनी
मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशन फॉर योर फर्स्ट हॉल ऑफ
फेम एट नासा एंड ये बहुत बड़ी अचीवमेंट है
बहुत लोगों को ऐसा लगता है कि एक हॉल ऑफ
फेम मिलने से मतलब क्या ही हो जाएगा या
पॉइंट्स मिलने से क्या ही हो जाएगा तो मैं
आपको एक बात बता दे देता हूं जब भी एक
बिगनर जब साइबर सिक्योरिटी में कुछ अचीव
करता है वो अचीवमेंट उसके लिए बड़ी होनी
चाहिए उसको वैसे ही सेलिब्रेट करनी चाहिए
क्योंकि वो आपको एक इनकरेजमेंट देती है
जिस इनकरेजमेंट का यूज करके आप आगे और भी
चीजें अचीव कर सकते हो बड़ी-बड़ी चीजें
अचीव करोगे तो वो छोटी-छोटी अचीवमेंट जो
है ना आपके लिए बहुत यूजफुल होने वाला है
आने वाले टाइम में ठीक
है हॉल ऑफ फेम मिल गया है वाओ क्या बात है
पियूष बढ़िया है लिंक न प डालो टैग मारो
मेनी मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशन फॉर योर हॉल ऑफ
फेम हेलो निखिल कहां थे निखिल कहां गायब
हो निखिल
बताओ सर अभी लर्निंग पे फोकस है ठीक है सर
भाई नेपाल का फर्स्ट नेपाल ओके ग्रेट
ग्रेट और कितना रह गया बहुत है यार बहुत
है काफी कम लोग आए हैं क्यों बात है क्या
क्या बात है यार नमस्ते नमस्ते आयुष काफी
कम लोग आए हैं अभी क्लास में काफी कम
लोगों ने जवाइन किया है यह अच्छी बात नहीं
है अगर आप लोग ज्यादा
संख्या में जवाइन नहीं करेंगे तो फिर यह
बहुत बड़ी डिस्क जमेंट है ठीक
है सर भगवंती के लिए सबसे अच्छा
प्लेटफार्म कौन सा है भगवंती के लिए नहीं
बग बाउंट के लिए तुम बोलना चाह रहे होगे
मुझे जहां तक लग रहा है मिस्टेक हुई होगी
टाइपो हुआ होगा तो बग बाउंटीज गह भगवंती
लिख दिया आपने तो बग बाउंटीज के लिए आप
कोई सा भी प्लेटफॉर्म चूज कर सकते हो बट
एक ऐसा प्लेटफार्म चूज करो जहां कि जो
टारगेट्स आपको मिल रहे हैं जहां पे जो
प्रोग्राम्स मिल रहे हैं वो बहुत ज्यादा
लाइक काइंड
ऑफ यू कैन से कि बहुत ज्यादा भीड़ ना हो
उस प्रोग्राम के अंदर रिसर्चस की वो
ज्यादा आपको बेनिफिशियल लगेगा ठीक
है चलिए मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए आप लोग
बताओ यार 100 प्लस 100 प्लस अबकी बार 200
पार का नारा लगाते हो यहां तो 100 प्लस भी
नहीं हो पाते हैं यह तो मतलब अलग ही हो
गया इस
बार चलो कोई ना देखते हैं मुझे आप लोग
बताइए आप लोगों में से किसके किन किन
क्लासेस तक कंप्लीट हो चुके हैं एकदम जेनन
ऑनेस्ट एंड सच्चाई के साथ बताइएगा कितने
क्लासेस तक आपने कर लिए हैं अभी क्लास
नंबर 35 चल रही है आपने कौन से क्लास तक
कंप्लीट कर लिया है हमारी जो अभी क्लासेस
चल रही है मुझे बता दीजिए जल्दी
से एथिकल हैकिंग के अलावा किस पर ध्यान दू
बक बाउंट के अलावा कोडिंग प्रोग्रामिंग पर
ध्यान दे सकते हो बट ज्यादा चीजों पर एक
साथ ध्यान मत दो 30 34 बहुत बढ़िया क्लास
20 पूरा कंप्लीट है बहुत बढ़िया ऑल बहुत
बढ़िया 10 31 ठीक
है ला रहे हम इंटर्नशिप ला रहे टेंशन मत
लो ठीक है बढ़िया चलिए तो सबसे पहले आज की
क्लास को स्टार्ट करें उसके पहले मैं कुछ
चीजें आपको बताना चाहता हूं वो चीज आप
थोड़ा सा सुन लीजिए समझ लीजिए ज्यादा बेटर
होगा ठीक है एंड कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है जो
आपसे डिस्कस करनी है वह भी हम करेंगे ठीक
है नेपाल का फर्स्ट हंटर हू क्या बात है
कांग्रेचुलेशन एसक्यूएल फिनिश ट्स ग्रेट
आई एम ग्लैड टू हियर दैट यर एसक्यूएल
फिनिश्ड कीप अप द गुड गुड वर्क इफ यू नीड
एनी
असिस्टेंट आस्क ट् ग्रेट ठीक है थ थैंक्स
भाई
लोजन मजा आ
गया चलिए तो सबसे पहले ये हमारे डिफ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का लिंकन पेज है आप को जरूर
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा सारी अपडेट सब चीजें
हमारी कंपनी से रिलेटेड आपको यही मिलेंगी
ये हमारी कंपनी का एक नया एक ऑफलाइन
चैप्टर वेंचर आप बोल सकते हैं द इंफोसेक
डायरी स्टार्ट होने वाला है प्रोसेस में
है बहुत जल्द आपको इसकी गुण अ जो अ इसके
जो आवाजें हैं वो सुनाई देने लगेंगी
मार्केट के अंदर में यह हमारा डेनिक्स का
ठीक
है चलिए अब एक चीज और बता देता हूं आप
लोगों
को सर डिजिटल फॉरसिस में सबसे पहले कौन सी
स्किल सीखनी होगी अ देखो मैं आपको बताता
हूं बेसिक तो नॉलेज होनी चाहिए बेसिक
नॉलेज अगर आपके पास नहीं है तो थोड़ी सी
मुश्किल आपको होती है चाहे वो आप कोई सा
भी टेक्निक सीखते हैं या स्पेशली जब
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक की बात करते हैं जो कि एक
तरह का डोमेन है साइबर सिक्योरिटी का ही
एक पार्ट है ठीक है तो बेसिक आप थोड़ा सा
रखिए अपना अच्छा बाकी सब आप स्क्रैच से
सीख सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है एक
सिस्टमैटिक वे में ठीक है तो चलिए मैं
आपको एक चीज और बता देता हूं गाइस अभी आप
लोग देख रहे हो ना ये चलो एक मुझे
क्वेश्चन का आप आंसर दे दो पता है आपने इस
अभी ट्रेनिंग क्लास के अंदर में 100 से भी
ज्यादा नहीं हो रहे हैं मतलब 100 भी लाइव
ट्रेनिंग में अभी यहां पे बंदे नहीं आ पा
रहे ठीक है 100 भी नहीं है और ऐसा नहीं है
कि आज मंडे है इसलिए नहीं है सैटरडे संडे
को भी होता है क्लास अगर तो भी नहीं होते
हैं अब ये बहुत अ एक एक थॉटफुल बात है जो
कि मैं सोच रहा था एंड मुझे ऐसा लगता है
कि कोई भी
जो एक कंटेंट क्रिएटर है या एक यूटर है या
कोई भी एक टीचर है ट्रेनर है जब वह कोई
कोर्स लॉन्च करता है ना जिसकी प्राइसेस वह
5000 10000 20000 ऐसे रखता है देन उसमें
जो स्टूडेंट्स इनरोल करते हैं तब वह
एक्चुअली टाइम देते हैं उस पर्टिकुलर चीज
के अंदर में एंड दे इन्वेस्ट देर टाइम दे
थिंक सीरियसली अबाउट दोस थिंग्स उनको वो
सीरियसली मतलब सोचना होता है वो सोचते हैं
सीरियसली एंड वो उसके लिए टाइम निकालते
हैं एक्चुअली बट यहां पे बग बाउंटीज के इस
क्लासेस में या बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट मिल
रहा है सबको कोई किसी भी तरह का किसी भी
तरह का कोई लाइक ऐसा कुछ रूल नहीं है कि
आपको आना ही है या ऐसा कुछ साथ में आपको
रिकॉर्डिंग्स
youtube4 ग्रांटेड लेते हैं जितने
स्टूडेंट्स हैं उनको लगता है अरे चलो यार
आ ही रही है क्लासेस देख लेंगे जब मर्जी
देख लेंगे कौन सा भाग जा रहा है तो इसको
सीरियसली नहीं लेते हैं एंड इस वजह से
मैंने सोचा है मैं सोच रहा हूं ना कि बग
बाउंटीज की क्लासेस को बंद कर दी जाए लाइक
मैंने तो सोचा था 100 प्लस वीडियोस की
क्लासेस के इनफैक्ट मैं सच बता रहा हूं बट
पता नहीं क्यों अंदर से ऐसी कुछ आ नहीं
रही है आ नहीं रही है मतलब मुझे तो बड़ा
मन होता है मुझे बहुत मन है कि भाई मैं
कराऊं
पढ़ाऊंगा एनालिस्ट बनने का रिसर्चर बनने
का एक बग बाउंट हंटर बनने का तो ये चीज
मैंने सोचा
कि 35 क्लासेस हो चुकी है
दैट्ची क्या सोचा है कि जितनी वीडियोस हैं
बग बाउंटीज की यहां पे आपकी इस सीरीज के
अंदर उनको प्राइवेट कर देने का और
एक्सेसिबल नॉन एक्सेसिबल बना देने का
जितने भी अभी तक वीडियोज आए हैं यानी 35
वीडियोस को नॉन एक्सेसिबल कर देने का इसका
भी रीजन मैं आपको बता देता हूं जिन लोगों
ने लाइव देखा वो तो देख लिया अच्छी बात है
उन्होंने सीखा नोट्स बनाया जो भी किया
जिन्होंने नहीं देखा सीरियसली नहीं ले रहे
हैं वो डिजर्व नहीं करते हैं मैं सच बता
रहा हूं दे आर नॉट डिजर्विंग क्यों मैं
बोल रहा हूं अब सोच रहे होगे अरे ऐसा
क्यों बोल रहे हो आप तो बोलते हो नहीं
होगा यह वो ऐसा अब यह मैं इसलिए बोल रहा
हूं क्योंकि मुझे बिल्कुल अच्छा नहीं लग
रहा जब आप लोग नहीं आते हो लाइव क्लासेस
में फ्री की क्लासेस है जो नॉलेज दे रही
है ना यहां पे दी जा रही है इस क्लास के
अंदर में पाच 10000 की कोर्सेस करोगे ना
नहीं मिलेगा वैसा एक्सप्लेनेशन वैसी
बिल्कुल बिगनर लेवल से बेसिक से नहीं
मिलेगा गारंटी देता हूं मिल जाएगा तो बता
देना ठीक है पहली चीज ये चीज समझ में आ
गया अब दूसरी चीज कुछ लोग हैं जो बहुत
सीरियस है डेली आते हैं सब कुछ करते हैं
उनके लिए ये चीजें मैं नहीं बोल रहा जो
सीरियस है डेली आते हैं रेगुलर व्यूवर्स
हैं रेगुलर क्लास में आते हैं अटेंडेंस
लगाते हैं उनके लिए यह बातें नहीं है यह
बातें उनके लिए हैं जो जो मजाक ले रहे हैं
मजाक की तरह ले रहे हैं इस सीरीज को तो
मेरा देखो बड़ा बड़ी बात क्या है पता है
बड़ी बात यह नहीं है कंटेंट डिलीवरी मैं
कर रहा हूं मेरा टाइम जा रहा है नहीं आप
उस टाइम की कदर नहीं कर रहे हो आप खुद
सोचो ना एक क्वेश्चन आपसे पूछता हूं आप
सभी से मैं क्वेश्चन पूछता हूं एवरीवन कैन
आंसर आप मान लो घर में हो सबकी फैमिली है
राइट अब आप कुछ चीजें कर रहे हो घर में आप
बहुत मेहनत का कोई काम कर रहे हो बहुत
एफर्ट लगा के कर रहे हो और आपके उस मेहनत
को कोई अप्रिशिएट ना कर रहा हो मतलब उसको
इग्नोर कर रहे हैं लोग तो आपको कैसा लगेगा
हाउ यू विल फील आपको मन करेगा वो काम करने
का नहीं करेगा यू विल फील नॉट टू डू दैट
थिंग वो एप्रिसिएशन कैसे अब मुझे ये नहीं
पता मुझे ये नहीं चाहिए कि आप लोग आके
बोलो थैंक यू सर थैंक यू आपने बगवां से ना
आप बस लाइव आ जाओ यही मेरा थैंक यू यही
मेरा सब कुछ एप्रिसिएशन यही मेरी हर एक
चीज है जो मुझे चाहिए और
लोग जो लिंकन प पोस्ट करते हैं अपनी जर्नी
को मैंने कई बार बोला है जो बक बाउंटीज
में कर रहे हो जो पर्टिकुलर
तुम चीजें सीख रहे हो जो टास्क कर रहे हो
जो भी चीजें हंट कर रहे हो उसका रिपोर्ट
बना बना के डालो लिंकन पे इससे तुम्हारी
लिंकन प्रोफाइल भी अच्छी होती है कोई
रिक्रूटर देखेगा अरे भाई लिंकन पे ऐसे ऐसे
पोस्ट करता है यह चीजें सीख रहा है करा
हुआ है तो काफी अच्छा एक इंप्रेशन बनता है
फिर हमें टैग करो डिफ्रॉक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी को क्या ही जाएगा
राइट व भी तुम नहीं कर रहे हो
बस तो इतना ही बोलना था बस और कुछ नहीं है
80 हो गए 90 हो गए इस से मतलब नहीं है
ब्रदर कासिम उससे मतलब नहीं है मतलब है कि
आप वो रेगुलेरिटी नहीं समझ में आ रही है
मुझे ठीक है तो चलो आज की क्लास तो मैं
लेता हूं आगे क्लासेस का मुझे नहीं पता
देखते हैं क्या किस तरह से सिस्टम रहता है
उस हिसाब से करेंगे आपका क्या रिस्पांस
रहता है ग्रुप में भी काफी ढीले हो गए हैं
लोग बहुत लोग काफी धीरे-धीरे करते हैं ठीक
है तो मैं य बोल रहा हूं बिकॉज मुझे मजा
नहीं आ रहा इसलिए बोल रहा हूं और कोई बात
नहीं ठीक है चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते हैं आज
की क्लास जो बोलना था मैंने बोल दिया है
आई होप कि आप सब समझेंगे इस बात को आप सब
इस बात को थोड़ा सिंसियर
लेंगे एंड देन उसी तरीके से करेंगे आपके
लिए बोला जा रहा है चलिए तो एसकल इंजेक्शन
हम कर रहे थे आप सबको पता ही है एसकल
इंजेक्शन दिस इज द पार्ट थ्री एंड दिस इज
द फाइनल पार्ट राइट फाइनल पार्ट
ओके चलिए अब देखिए एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन में
मैंने आपको पहले बहुत सारी चीजें ऑलरेडी
बता दी है एरर बेस्ड हो गया यूनियन बेस्ड
हो गया बुलियन हो गया इन सबके कंसेप्ट
मैंने आपको समझा दिए हैं ठीक है कि भाई
क्या कंसेप्ट होता है किस कंसेप्ट पे काम
करता है किस पर्टिकुलर कांसेप्ट पे एल
इंजेक्शन एक्चुअली वर्क करता है आप सबको
यह बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है कि आप एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन के पार्ट वन एंड पार्ट टू को
जरूर देखें इस पार्ट को देखने से पहले अगर
आपने नहीं देखा तो आप देख सकते हैं देख
जरूर लीजिएगा ठीक है ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है
काफी आपको चीजें सीखने को
मिलेगी चलो आज जो हम बात करने वाले हैं
थोड़ा सा ऑटोमेशन पे बात करेंगे थोड़ा सा
ऑटोमेटिक टूल्स के बारे में बात करेंगे और
एक ऐसे टूल के बारे में बात करेंगे जिसका
यूज जो है ना वो बग बाउंट हंटर्स एंड
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चस करते हैं ड्यूरिंग
फाइंडिंग ऑफ द स्कल इंजेक्शन लेबिलिटी उस
टूल का नाम है एसक्यूएल मैप ठीक है यह टूल
आपके काली लिनिक्स में प्री डिफाइन यानी
प्री इंस्टॉल्ड मिल जाता है आप काली नेक्स
में आपको इंस्टॉल करने की जरूरत नहीं है
अदर वाइज अगर आप कोई और डिस्ट्रॉय यूज़ कर
रहे हैं तो आप इसके गिट हब रिपोजिटरी पे
जा सकते हैं एएल मैप के जो कि ये वाली है
यहां पे आप आएंगे एएल मैप पे यहां पे यहां
पे एएल मैप पे आ जाता हूं मैं तो यहां पे
आपको सिंपली इसको क्लोन करना होता है
क्लोन कर लीजिएगा उसके बाद
कैसे आपको इंस्टॉल करना है जस्ट फॉलो द
वर्जन एंड यू कैन जस्ट इंस्टॉल इट चलिए
काली
ओके तो चलिए ये स्टार्ट हो रहा है इसको
स्टार्ट होने देते हैं उसके पहले हम चलते
हैं यहां पर हमारे टेस्ट पीएचपी one
web.com ठीक है t
ph.com इस वाली वेबसाइट पे जो हमारी
वेबसाइट है टेस्टिंग वेबसाइट है इस पर हम
आ चुके हैं ठीक है अब देखो आपका क्वेश्चन
यह होगा कि सर कैसे हमें पता चलेगा कि कौन
सा किस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल पे या टारगेट पे
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन फाइंड करना है तो उसके
लिए ना आपको फाइंड करनी होती है
पैरामीटर्स फाइंड
पैरामीटर्स अब उस पैरामीटर्स पे टेस्ट फॉर
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन ऑन
दोज पैरामीटर्स अब टेस्टिंग कैसे करनी है
एसकल इंजेक्शन की पैरामीटर्स प आप सबको
पता है क्या बताइए मुझे मैं देख रहा हूं
चैट बताइए आपको यह तो पता होगा ना कि
पैरामीटर्स अगर आपको मिल गई तो टेस्टिंग
कैसे करनी है पैरामीटर प यह पता है ना
सबको कि टेस्टिंग कैसे करनी है एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन के लिए कि एसक्यूएल वल्नरेबल है
या नहीं है यह बता दिया ना
मैंने ये लास्ट क्लासेस में बताया था ना
मैंने फॉरवर्ड स्लैश लगा के सिंगल कोट डबल
कोट सिंगल कोट क्लोजिंग यह सब लगा के
राइट या या राइट आइडेंटिफिकेशन
पैरामीटर्स कहां से मिलेगी तो भैया आप
पैरामीटर्स निकाल सकते हो देयर आर मल्टीपल
मेथड्स पहला बात तो आप सबसे बढ़िया तरीका
जो होता है वो क्रॉल करके जैसे कि बॉब शूट
की मैं बात कर रहा हूं तो बॉब शूट में
आपको पैरामीटर्स निकालने आना हो आना चाहिए
लाइक आपको आता होगा बॉब शूट में
पैरामीटर्स निकालना तो जैसे कि मैं अपना
बब शूट एक बार ओपन कर लेता हूं ठीक है लेट
मी ओपन द बब शूट
हियर ठीक है यहां बब शूट मैं ओपन कर रहा
हूं ठीक है यहां पे चलते हैं प्रॉक्सी
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते हैं यहां पे मैं
बब प्रॉक्सी को इनेबल कर देता हूं डन नाउ
यहां मैं प्रॉक्सी ऑन करके एंड इनको
इंटरसेप्ट कर लेता हूं इस पर्टिकुलर पेज
को यहां इंटरसेप्ट हो गया टेस्ट पीएचपी
इसको मैं सेंड टू स्पाइडर कर देता हूं
स्कोप मैं ऐड कर देता हूं एंड यस एंड
स्पाइडरिंग के लिए भेज देता हूं अब यहां
पे आप देख रहे होंगे कि ये पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट जो है वो क्या हो रहा
है क्रॉल हो रहा है ठीक है
ये देखिए क्रोलिम स्टार्ट हो गई यहां पे
तो आपने बब शूट का यूज किया एंड इसको क्या
किया क्रॉल स्टार्ट की ठीक है भैया तो ये
क्रॉ ंग हो रही है अच्छी बात है अब आप
पैरम वाली फिल्टर जो है ना यहां पे पैरम
पैरम वाली फिल्टर को डबल क्लिक करेंगे तो
आपको जितने भी टिक वाले यूआरएल मिल रहे
हैं यहां पे यह सब
पैरामीटर्स जो है पैरामीटर्स इस इन सब के
अंदर पैरामीटर्स है कोई ना कोई एक
पैरामीटर है चाहे वो हेडर के अंदर में हो
चाहे वो बॉडी के अंदर में हो तो यहां पर
पैरामीटर अवेलेबल है ओके पहली बात अब यहां
पे पैरामीटर यही हो जैसे कि मान लो ये
पैरामीटर अब स्टेटस 200 मतलब वही वर्किंग
लिंक है आपका 2 ओके यानी कि आप एक्सेसिबल
है ये यूआरएल अब यहां पे जैसे ये वाली एक
लिंक है आप इस पे आएंगे तो यहां पे
पैरामीटर क्या है आर्टिस्ट इ 1 देखो तो
आर्टिस्ट पैरामीटर यहां पे पैरामीटर कौन
सा है आर्टिस्ट चलिए ये कार्ड ड पीएपी
यहां आते है नीचे आते हैं यहां देखो ऐड
काट ये पैरामीटर प्राइस ये पैरामीटर एक
पैरामीटर मिल गया गेस्ट बुक इसमें आ जाते
है नीचे नेम पैरामीटर सबमिट पैरामीटर यह
पैरामीटर्स है अब आपको पैरामीटर जहां भी
मिले वह बॉडी में मिले हेडर में मिले कहीं
भी कुकीज में मिल रहे हैं कहीं भी मिल रहे
हैं ना यू कैन जस्ट गो एंड ट्राई एंड
ट्राई टू फाइंड दैट वेदर इट इज वल्नरेबल
टू एकल इंजेक्शन और नॉट जो कि मैंने आपको
बताया हुआ है कैसे आपको फाइंड करना है अब
इसका मैं एक सिंपल सा एग्जांपल देता हूं
जैसे ये एक टेस्ट पीएचपी वेबसाइट
है जैसे यह क्या है यह क्या है टेस्ट
पीएचपी एक वेबसाइट है यहां आएंगे यहां पे
आने के बाद आपको चलना है मान लो मैं यहां
पर चलता हूं कैटेगरी पे कैटेगरी पे आ गए
यहां पे यहां पे आ रहे है कैटेगरी यहां
कोई से भी एक कैटेगरी पर क्लिक कर देते
हैं जैसे ही हमने क्लिक किया यहां ऊपर का
यूआरएल आप देखिए आप ऊपर का क्या देखिए
यूआरएल देखिए इस य ph.com
एन एरर इन योर एसक्यूएल सिंटेक्स चेक द
मैनुअल दैट करेस्पॉन्ड्स टू योर माय
एसक्यूएल सर्वर वर्जन एंड इसके बाद ये
सिंगल कोड एट द लाइन वन तो अब ये आपको तो
पता है भैया ये सिंगल कोट आप देख रहे हो
सब कुछ देख रहे हो अब आपको किस तरीके से
एरर को हैंडल करना है एरर को हटाना है फिर
उसके बाद अ सॉल्व करना है उसको फिर आपको
ऑर्डर बाय यूनियन ये सारी चीजें आपने
मैनुअल वाले में देखा है बट हमें अभी
ऑटोमेटिक ले ऑटोमेटिक यूज़ करना है
ऑटोमेटिक टूल का यूज़ करके एक ट्राई करना
है जब एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन फाइंड करने का तो
व्ट वी विल डू वी विल ट्राई टू गेट द
पैरामीटर दैट आर वल्नरेबल टू एसल इंजेक्शन
तो यह पैरामीटर क्या है एसकल इंजेक्शन से
वल्नरेबल है क्या है भाई
य अरे भाई
टेस्ट द टॉप जी सुपर चैट करने की जरूरत
नहीं है आप हमारे ट नंबर जो है ना अब
स्क्रीन पर आपको नीचे दिख रहा होगा उस परे
कांटेक्ट कर लीजिएगा ठीक
है ओके इशा
अ अ देखते हैं अभी तो क्या करते हैं लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी व्हाट वी आर
डूइंग चलिए तो यहां पे पैरामीटर में मिल
गया और हमें एक एरर भी मिल चुके है इसका
मतलब है यह जो पैरामीटर है पर्टिकुलर यह
वल्नरेबल है एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन के तो अब
जो है हम एक बहुत पॉपुलर टूल का यूज
करेंगे एसक्यूएल मैप टू फाइंड एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन वलने बिलिटी या टू एक्सप्लोइट द
एए वाला बिलिटी अब देखो यह टूल का यूज कर
लोगे आप ब बाउंट वगैरह में भी कर सकते हो
एंड सभी लोग लगभग करते हैं तो यह टूल जो
चीज करता है ना बैकग्राउंड में वो चीज
आपने सीख ली है वो चीज आपने सीख ली है पता
है दो एक चीज पता है आपको नब नब की मैं नब
नहीं बोलूंगा
मैं स्क्रिप्ट
किडी ठीक है स्क्रिप्ट किडी
वर्सेस रियल
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट इन दोनों में एक बहुत
ही माइनर सा डिफरेंस होता है पता है
डिफरेंस क्या होता है मैं आपको बताता हूं
कैसे आप समझेंगे कि सामने वाला एक
स्क्रिप्ट कीडी है ओनली या एक रियल
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट है या एक एथिकल हैकर
है या एक बग बाउंट हंटर है या एक
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट है रियल वाला है नॉट
जस्ट स्क्रिप्ट किडी स्क्रिप्ट किडी का
मतलब आपको पता ही है कि टूल्स का जो टूल
कहीं पे बनी हुई है पहले से टूल्स डेवलप्ड
है जो भी है उसको जस्ट यूज कर
लेना और उसके बारे में कुछ पता ही ना होना
दैट इज इ कॉल्ड स्क्रिप्ट किडी बहुत सारे
जो बिगिनर्स होते हैं वो स्क्रिप्ट किडीज
होते हैं जस्ट टूल का यूज कर लेते हैं
एसक्यूएल मैप मिला ना एसक्यूएल मैप चला
लेंगे एसक्यूएल मैप के सारे फंक्शन सारे
यूज केसेस को यूज कर लेंगे सारे उसके
ऑप्शन आर्गुमेंट सब चीज यूज कर लेंगे उसको
चला भी लेंगे एग्जीक्यूट कर लेंगे वनबिल
भी फाइंड कर लेंगे बट उनको पता ही नहीं
चलेगा कि एसएल इंजेक्शन बैकग्राउंड में
क्या करता है बिहाइंड द सॉरी एसक्यूएल मैप
टूल बैकग्राउंड में क्या करता है बिहाइंड
द सीन उसका क्या-क्या चल रहा होता है क्या
क्या वो चीजें किस तरीके से कौन सा पेलोड
यूज कर रहा है क्या स्टेप्स यूज कर रहा है
टू फाइंड द पर्टिकुलर डेटाबेस या
एक्सप्लोइट द स्ल वल्नरेबल
टारगेट यह पता ही नहीं चलेगा तो स्क्रिप्ट
के लिए क्या हो जाता है यूज द टूल्स एज
यूज एस दे
आर एस दे आर विदाउट
नोइंग विदाउट नोइंग द बैकग्राउंड कांसेप्ट
अबाउट दोज
टूल्स ये स्क्रिप्ट किडी की डेफिनेशन है
इसको क्या बोलते हैं स्क्रिप्ट किडी बोलते
हैं चलिए अब यहां पे रियल सिक्योरिटी
एक्सपर्ट्स की बात करते हैं यहां पे हम
किसकी बात करते हैं रियल सिक्योरिटी
एक्सपर्ट चलिए यह क्या करते हैं
यूज द टूल्स यहां पे यूज द टूल्स नहीं यूज
द यूज अदर टूल्स यूज अदर्स
टूल्स टूल्स यह भी रियल सिक्योरिटी
एक्सपर्ट जो होता है ना यूज अदर्स
टूल्स ऐसा नहीं है कि रियल सिक्योरिटी
एक्सपर्ट्स हैं तो सारे टूल खुद ही डेवलप
करके उसको यूज करेंगे ऐसा नहीं है भाई यह
गलतफहमी मत रहना हर
कोई मैसेज मत करो बार-बार नहीं तो रिमूव
करना ही पड़ेगा
मैसेज करोगे तो वी हैव टू रिमूव थैंक यू
सईदुर रहमान लव यू टू ब्रदर तो अब रियल
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट जरूरी नहीं है कि वो
एक दूसरे का टूल यूज नहीं कर सकता सब टूल
खुद ही बनाएगा खुद ही अ यूज करेगा नॉट
लाइक दैट वो दूसरों का भी टूल यूज कर सकता
है बट बट दे दे विल बी
नोइंग ऑल द बैकग्राउंड
कांसेप्ट अबाउट
दैट टूल एंड देयर वर्किंग्स
ठीक है यह है एक रियल सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट
जो उस टूल के बैकग्राउंड कांसेप्ट के बारे
में जानता है और उसके रियल वर्किंग्स के
बारे में भी जानता है तो अब आप डिसाइड कर
लीजिएगा कि आपको स्क्रिप्ट डी बनना है या
रियल सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट बनना है और अगर
आप डि फ्रक्स के साथ है डि फ्रक्स के किसी
भी कोर्स में एनरोल्ड है वो पे पेड कोर्स
है या कोई फ्री कोर्स चल रही है जैसे
हमारी यह कैप्सूल कोर्स बग बाउंट की
क्लासेस चल रही है यह कोर्स है या फ्यूचर
में या जो भी कोर्सेस है ना अगर आप डि
फ्रक्स के साथ है तो आप ये स्क्रिप्ट किडी
नहीं कहलाएंगे आप कहलाएंगे रियल
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट क्योंकि हमारा मोटिव
हमारा विजन हमारा मोटो ही यही है कि जो भी
हम बताएंगे सिखाएंगे चाहे वो फ्री में
सिखाएं व पेड सिखाएं कोर्सेस के थ्रू
सिखाएं किसी भी तरह से सिखाए हम इन डेप्थ
सिखाएंगे एंड एक पूरा कांसेप्ट के साथ
सिखाएंगे ऐसे फालतू कुछ भी नहीं फेंक
देंगे कि लो भाई ये कर लो अब एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन में एसक्यूएल मैप का यूज करना
बहुत आसान है कोई भी यूज कर सकता है एक
बच्चा भी एएल इंजेक्शन के कमांड्स को
निकाल के एसक्यूएल मैप के कमांड्स को
निकाल के और एएल इंजेक्शन परफॉर्म कर सकता
है टारगेट्स पे फाइंड भी कर सकता है हो
सकता है बग मिल जाए बट वो फिर रियल
एक्सपर्ट है ऐसा नहीं बोल सकते जब तक उसको
एक्चुअल में पता नहीं है कि बैकग्राउंड
में हो क्या रहा है भैया तो यह समझ में
आपकी आ गई होगी चलिए तो यहां पे हम
टर्मिनल को ओपन कर लेते हैं छोटा सा
प्यारा सा टर्मिनल हमारा एंड अब जो है
हमारा फिलहाल के लिए एक हमारी जो टारगेट
है टेस्ट टारगेट वह है यह वाली इस टारगेट
को हम यूज करने वाले
हैं ठीक है अब इस टारगेट को हम रोज अब
कैसे यूज करेंगे एसक्यूएल मैप के थ्रू अब
देखो एसक्यूएल मैप जो है ना यह अपने आप
में एक बहुत ही बहुत
ही बहुत ही एडवांस टूल मैं बोलूंगा फॉर
फाइंडिंग एसकल इंजेक्शन बहुत एडवांस टूल
है
इसका टूल इस जो इस टूल का सही से यूज करना
अगर आपको आएगा ना तभी आप इसके कंप्लीट
आउटकम को कंप्लीट रिजल्ट को ना आप सामने
लेकर आ पाएंगे और इसको परफेक्टली यूज कर
पाएंगे बहुत अब देखो दो तरीके से यहां पे
ना दो चीजें मैं आपको बता रहा हूं दो
चीजें मैं आपको बताता हूं एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन के लिए एसक्यूएल मैप टूल का यूज
दो बंदे मान लो कर रहे हैं चलो आप ही में
से कोई ले रहे हैं चलो ठीक है आप में से
कोई दो बंदे ले लेते हैं एक प्रियांशु ले
लेते हैं एक साहिद उर रहमान ले लेते मान
लो ये दोनों एल मैप ही यूज कर रहे एक ही
टारगेट पर यूज कर रहे अब मान लो कि
प्रियांशु को थोड़ा ज्यादा ना ज्यादा इन
पता है स्ल मैप के बारे में और सादर रहमान
को थोड़ा उससे कम तो सेम टारगेट के लिए
सेम पर्टिकुलर वल्नरेबल पैरामीटर पर जो
प्रियांशु है ना इस टूल का यूज करके
डेटाबेस निकाल लेगा और डंप कर लेगा
डेटाबेस को और यदुर रहमान जो है वह नहीं
कर पाएगा क्योंकि उसने यदुर ने कुछ
पर्टिकुलर
शस को आर्गुमेंट को सही से यूज नहीं किया
एल मैप टूल के अंदर क्योंकि एसक्यूएल मैप
के अंदर ना बहुत सारे आर्गुमेंट है ऑप्शंस
है वह ऑप्शंस को समझना जरूरी है अगर आप
कोई एक ऑप्शन है मान लो टेंपर तो वह क्या
है टेक्निक तो वह क्या है समझना है बैच व
क्या
है फ्लश करना वह क्या है टाइम सेकंड वो
है कीपिंग अलाइव वो क्या है
देर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स मल्टीपल ऑप्शन ट यू
हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड टू यूज एसल मैप एसल
इतना भी ऐसे नहीं है कि बस एसकल के कमांड
डाला यह डाला वो डाला कहीं से ग से उठाया
और चेप दिया खत्म भैया मिलेगा ही नहीं
आपको वल्नरेबल डेटाबेस
मतलब डेटाबेस मिलेगा नहीं आपको लिख के रखो
हेलो निशा तो अब चलिए एसक्यूएल मैप को
समझते हैं तो देखो एल मैप को समझने के लिए
सबसे पहले तो एसक्यूएल मैप हेल्प फाइल
आपको देखनी पड़ेगी अब ये हेल्प फाइल कैसे
देखेंगे एसक्यूएल मैप हाई फन हाई फन हेल्प
लिख दीजिए एंटर कर दीजिए एसक्यूएल मैप की
हेल्प फाइल आपको आ जाएगी बट इसकी जब हेल्प
फाइल आप देखेंगे ना तो इसकी हेल्प फाइल जो
है ना हेल्प
फाइल यह बहुत ही छोटा दिखेगा यहां पे जैसे
आप देखिए यहां पे कुछ ऑप्शंस दे रखे हैं
टारगेट के लिए यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट ऑप्शंस
दे रखे हैं इंजेक्शन ऑप्शन दे रखे हैं
डिटेक्शन ऑप्शंस दे रखे हैं टेक्निक ऑप्शन
दे रखे हैं नमरे ऑप्शंस दे रखे हैं
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम दे रख जनरल देखे कुछ
मिसलेनियस दे रखे सिर्फ अब इतने ही ऑप्शंस
नहीं है इसमें तो और भी ज्यादा ऑप्शंस
देखने हैं ना और भी ज्यादा ऑप्शन इसके
देखने तो आप इसका मैनुअल पे चेक कीजिए मैन
स्पेस एसक्यूएल
मैप और एंटर
कीजिए जब आप एंटर करेंगे ना तो यहां पर
आपको पूरी की पूरी इसकी मैनुअल पेज मिलेगी
जो आप माउस से स्क्रॉल कर सकते हैं या पेज
अप पेज डाउन बटन आपके कीबोर्ड प होता है
उससे भी आप उसको स्क्रॉल कर सकते हैं अब
देखो अब
देखो यह देखा तुमने यह चीजें प्रॉक्सी टोर
टेक टोर यह सब यह सब क्या है भाई व्हाट आर
दीज पैरामीटर्स यह पैरामीटर्स है क्या यह
भी तो समझना है ना डीबीएमएस है लेवल है
रिस्क है टेक्निक है अब इन सबको बिना समझे
अगर एसक्यूएल मैप यूज कर लोगे तो कोई
बेनिफिट नहीं है कोई फायदा नहीं है और
आपको दिक्कत आएगी ही एज सिंपल एज दैट अब
यह जो आपकी पर्टिकुलर मैन पेज है ना इससे
भी डिटेल में इसकी जो रिपोजिटरी है वहां
पर आपको देखने को मिलेगी तो मैं यहां से
क्विट कर देता हूं क्यू दबा के और मैं
क्या कर देता हूं मैं एसक्यूएल मैप के
रिपोजिटरी पर चलता
हूं यह रही एएल मैप की डिफॉल्ट रिपोजिटरी
जो कि है एसकल मैप प्रोजेक्ट स् एएल मैप
अब इसमें आपको आना है विकी पेज पे
विकी ठीक है यहां आ गए विकी पेज पे अब
विकी पेज पे आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको राइट
साइड में यहां पे आपको मैनुअल दिखेगा
इंट्रोडक्शन टेक्निक्स फीचर्स सारा कुछ
दिख रहा है इंट्रोडक्शन पे क्लिक कर लेते
हैं यह आ गई हमारी इंट्रोडक्शन जब आप इस
पे जाएंगे तो आपको पूरा इंट्रो मिलेगा इस
टूल के बारे में उसके बाद टेक्निक्स आएंगे
तो टेक्निक्स के बारे में आपको पता चलेगा
कि यह कौन-कौन से टेक्निक्स यूज कर सकते
हैं अब देखो बुलियन बेस्ड टाइम बेस्ड एरर
बेस्ड यूनियन बेस्ड टैग क्वेरीज ये सारी
आपकी टेक्निक्स है जिसके बारे में हमने
पहले ही देखा हुआ है अब आते हैं फीचर्स के
ऊपर में तो यह सारे फीचर्स हैं जो आप
इसमें देख सकते हैं बहुत सारे देयर आर
मल्टीपल फीचर्स दैट यू कैन सी हियर तो इन
फीचर्स को आप देख सकते हैं ये आप देख
लीजिएगा डाउनलोड एंड अपडेट्स में जैसे
अपडेट वगैरह करना है डाउनलोड इंस्टॉलेशन
का जो है वो आप देख सकते हैं लाइक आप इसको
पिप से भी कर सकते हैं लाइक लेटेस्ट वर्जन
को
रिट्राईंग यहां पे आ जाते हैं डिपेंडेंसीज
इसको कोई मतलब नहीं है यूसेज सबसे जरूरी
जो चीजें हमारी है यूसेज सबसे ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है वो है यूसेज को यहां देखना
अब जब आप यूसेज सेक्शन पे आएंगे ना तो आप
देखेंगे इसकी जो यूसेज सेक्शन है बहुत
ज्यादा बहुत एडवांस बहुत ज्यादा इलब फॉर्म
में आपको यहां मिलेगा इतना आपको मैनुअल जो
आपकी हेल्प फाइल है ना स्कल इंजेक्शन की
उसमें आपको इतना
लेबोरेटरीज को यूज करेंगे समझते हैं बट
इसको लाइव देखते हुए लाइव इसको एक्शन में
लाते हुए
चलिए सबसे
पहले एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन को परफॉर्म करने
के लिए एएल मैप का जो सिंटेक्स होता है
सिंपल सा वो होता है एएल मैप हान य य से
आप यूआरएल टारगेट देते हैं अब आप सोच रहे
हैं कि यूआरएल टारगेट कौन सा टारगेट भाई
तो चलिए मैं एक बार इस पर्टिकुलर लिंक को
यहां अपने काली में ही ओपन कर लेता हूं
ताकि बार-बार मुझे टैब स्विच नहीं करना
पड़ेगा इधर विंडोज से काली एंड काली में
ही हम अपना स्विच करते रहेंगे तो लेट्स
स्टार्ट द firefox.exe
इट्स
ओपनिंग चलिए ये ओपन हो चुका अब हम यहां से
आई थिंक टैब को डायरेक्ट डायरेक्ट चेंज कर
सकते हैं यहां पे अच्छा
रहेगा चलिए एएल मैप के बाद हान य देना है
आपको यूआरएल के लिए अगर आपके पास एक सिंगल
टारगेट यूआरएल है तो आप हान य दीजिएगा हान
डी आप दीजिएगा किसके लिए कनेक्शन स्ट्रिंग
फॉर डायरेक्ट डेटाबेस कनेक्शन के लिए हान
ए लॉग फाइल से अगर कुछ करना है पास लॉग
फाइल अगर बब शूट का है तो वहां से आप कर
सकते हैं हान m जो हमारे के लिए यूज़फुल
हो सकता है स्कैन मल्टीपल टारगेट्स गिवन
इन अ टेक्चुअल फाइल यानी कि अगर आप किसी
टेक्स्ट फाइल में मल्टीपल टारगेट्स है एल
इंजेक्शन के लिए तो आप h m का यूज़ कर
सकते हैं एंड उनको डिफाइन कर सकते हैं
टेक्स्ट फाइल को ठीक है ये रिक्वेस्ट फाइल
है
google3 कोई कॉन्फिन फाइल है आईआई फाइल तो
वहां से आप इसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं ठीक है
चलिए अब यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट दिस ऑप्शंस कैन
बी यूज टू स्पेसिफाई हाउ टू कनेक्ट टू द
टारगेट यूआरएल अब ये ऑप्शंस रिक्वेस्ट
वाले किस लिए यूज में किया जाता है कि
टारगेट जो है ना आपका उससे कनेक्ट कैसे
किया जा सकता है हाउ यू कैन कनेक्ट टू द
टारगेट वो डिफाइन करने के लिए तो आपको
अलग-अलग चीजें जैसे हान ए यहां पे एजेंट
के लिए हान ए हेडर के लिए नफन डेटा डटा
स्ट्री अब देखो डाटा जैसे ये देखो हाइफान
इन मेथड अब कौन सा मेथड यूज करना है भाई
गेट पुट पोस्ट कौन सा मेथड यूज करना है
एचटीटीपी मेथड्स की बात कर रहा हूं ऑलरेडी
इस पे एक पूरी क्लास ली है आप उसको देख
लीजिएगा आपको समझ में आ जाएगा इसलिए पहले
ही क् क्लासेस वो ले रखी हैं बहुत लोग बोल
रहे थे पता है बहुत लोग जब अलग-अलग
क्लासेस मैंने ली है पहले तो बहुत लोग
बोलते हैं सर ये क्या क्लास क्लास करा रहे
हो आप बग बाउंटीज के अंदर यह कौन सी क्लास
लेकर आ रहे हो ये क्यों करा रहे हो इसकी
क्या जरूरत है ये एसटीटीपी कोड्स की
एसटीटीपी मेथड्स की तो भाई यही जरूरत है
इसी की जरूरत इसीलिए है क्योंकि आपको यहां
पे अब पता ही नहीं चलेगा पुट क्या होता है
अगर आपने नहीं करी है तो पता नहीं चलेगा
गेट पोस्ट क्या है अब यहां पे हाईफा फन
डाटा एक ऑप्शन है बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट ऑप्शन
है तो डाटा स्ट्रिंग्स टू बी सेंड थ्रू
पोस्ट मेथड एग्जांपल आईडी = 1 अब जैसे
आपको कोई पैरामीटर है ना आप पूरा का पूरा
मान लो ना जैसे कि पूरी की पूरी आपने यहां
पे क्या की यूआरएल दिया टारगेट आईडी के
साथ पैरामीटर के साथ मान लो आप पैरामीटर
के साथ यहां नहीं दे रहे हो आपने सिंपली
यूआरएल दिया तो आप जो पैरामीटर है ना उसको
यहां पे डिफाइन कर सकते हो हाइफान आईन
डाटा ऑप्शन के साथ इस तरीके से भी कर सकते
हो अगर आप चाहते हो तो यह तब अ यूज़फुल
होता है जब आप पोस्ट बेस एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शंस कर रहे होते हैं किसी फॉर्म
लॉगइन फॉर्म हो गया कांटेक्ट फॉर्म हो गया
वहां पे कोई स्कल इंजेक्शन आपको मिली है
पर्टिकुलर एक पेज पे तो वहां पे आपको
पर्टिकुलर
एक पैरामीटर मिल रहा है तो उस पैरामीटर को
आप यहां पे पास कर सकते हो हाईफा हाइफान
डाटा से ठीक है
चलिए अच्छा बहुत लोगों को क्या है ना
दिक्कत हो रही होगी इन द सेंस कि बहुत
लोगों को समझ में आ रहा होगा कि अरे यार
ये इतना क्यों डीप जा रहे हैं अरे सीधा
एसक्यूएल मैप चलाओ डालो और डेटाबेस निकालो
भाई ऐसे नहीं होता ऐसे फिर तो क्या फायदा
उससे उस लर्निंग का कोई बेनिफिट नहीं है
गाइस बिलीव मी कोई बेनिफिट नहीं है उस
लर्निंग का ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पे
अलग-अलग है पैराम है कुकी है कुकी यहां पे
मोबाइल है रैंडम एजेंट अब इसमें कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट जो पैरामीटर्स से मैं आपको वो
बताते चल रहा हूं जिसको हम यूज़ करेंगे या
जनरली जिसको जो है यूज किया जाता है आप भी
यूज करेंगे रैंडम एजेंट ये करना ज्यादा
अच्छा होता है यूज रैंडम सिलेक्टेड
एटीटीपी यूजर एजेंट हेडर वैल्यू जैसे कि
ये रैंडम जनरेट करता है आपका जो यूजर
एजेंट है यानी कि आप लाइक किस टाइप का
ब्राउजर किस टाइप की ब्राउजर मैकेनिज्म
यूज कर रहे हैं कौन सा ब्राउजर यूज कर रहे
हैं तो ये चेंज करके आपको देता रहता है
नफन होस्ट लगा सकते हैं एटीटीपी होस्ट
हेडर वैल्यू को अगर लाइक चेंज करना है कुछ
स्पेसिफिक मेंशन करना है तो ये आप डाल
सकते हैं रेफरल हेडर वैल्यू को अगर आपको
चेंज करना है लाइक होस्ट वैल्यू को चेंज
करना है तो होस्ट रेफरल वैल्यू को चेंज
करना है तो रेफरल ये सारी चीजें आप लगा
सकते हैं देन प्रॉक्सी अगर आपको यूज करना
है तो प्रॉक्सी का यूज आप कर सकते हैं कि
अगर आप लाइक थोड़ा स ऐसा चाहते हैं थोड़ा
सा एनोनिमस स्कैन करना चाहते हैं या
एनोनिमिटी दिखाना चाहते हैं वहां पे ठीक
है अपनी आइडेंटिटी को थोड़ा हाइड करना
चाहते हैं यू कैन यूज़ द h एफ प्रॉक्सी
देन आप h f टर यूज़ कर सकते हैं अगर आपको
टर यूज़ करना है टर के थ्रू आपको करनी है
यह एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन तो हान एफन टर यूज़
कीजिए इसके लिए आपका टर इंस्टॉल होना
चाहिए अगर आपको टर का नहीं पता तो मैं
आपको सिंपल बता देता हूं एप्ट इंस्टॉल टर
कर लीजिएगा आपका जो टर है वो इंस्टॉल हो
जाएगा यहां पे वाई करके इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिएगा उसके बाद टर की सर्विस होती है
उसको स्टार्ट कर लीजिएगा सर्विस टोर
स्टार्ट टोर की सर्विस स्टार्ट नहीं होगी
तो यह आपका जो पर्टिकुलर लर ऑप्शन है वो
काम नहीं करेगा तो टर की सर्विस स्टार्ट
होनी चाहिए ठीक है
दैट्ची क कर सकते हैं स्टार्टिंग में क्या
होता है टॉर की सर्विस जो है टॉर क्या है
एक एनोनिमस नेटवर्क है एक टनल है और कुछ
भी नहीं है जो यहां पे रिटा से पैकेज यहां
पे कोई जरूरत नहीं है यहां पे नो कर देते
हैं ओके तो ये अब जब जब ये इंस्टॉल हो
जाएगा तो आप इसकी सर्विस को चेक कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है देन आप इसको यहां पे मेंशन
करके और यूज कर सकते हैं भैया ट को तो आप
थोड़ा सा एनोनिमस थोड़ा एनोनिमिटी के साथ
आप एएल इंजेक्शन को परफॉर्म कर पाएंगे
एसक्यूएल आई एसक्यूएल मैप को यूज़ कर
पाएंगे और कोई बात नहीं है ठीक है अब यहां
पे आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं सर्विस टर स्टेटस
आप चेक करेंगे तो यह अभी इनक्टो यहां पे
इन एक्टिव लिखा रहा है जब स्टार्ट कर
देंगे तो एक्टिव हो जाएगा एंड देन यू कैन
यूज़ इनसाइड दिस पर्टिकुलर एएल मैप टूल
ठीक है टर की पोर्ट स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट आप
मेंशन कर सकते हैं डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट के अलावा
ठीक है च यह सब चेक कर सकते हैं चलो यह
हमारे काम की नहीं है उसके बाद नीचे आ
जाते हैं यहां पे हाइफान आईन इल अब देखो
ये भी एक इंपॉर्टेंट आपका ऑप्शन है मान लो
आपको पाइथन थन आती है अच्छे तरीके से
पाइथन आप जानते हो भैया ठीक
है आपके चैनल पर एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन काफी
है है हां हां भाई काफी है काफी है हमारे
चैनल पे बग बाउंट के सीरीज की जितनी
वीडियोस आ रही है जितने टॉपिक्स आ रहे हैं
जितनी भी क्लासेस हो रही है पर्टिकुलर
टॉपिक वो काफी है स्टार्ट करने के लिए
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक जाने के लिए बिना किसी
कोर्स के उस पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक को पढ़ने के
के लिए और उस टॉपिक में एक्सपर्ट बनने के
लिए अपने एक्सप्लोर करने के बाद या जब आप
से सेल्फ एक्सप्लोरेशन करेंगे लैब्स को
सॉल्व करेंगे हंट करेंगे एक्सप्लोर करके
प्रैक्टिस करेंगे तो एडवांस लेवल तक भी
जाने के लिए काफी है याद रखिएगा उसी टाइप
से मैं कराता हूं आपकी
क्लासेस चलिए तो यहां पे इवल हाइन एफन इवल
का यूज आप कर सकते हैं इवेलुएट प्रोवाइडेड
पाइथन कोड बिफोर द रिक्वेस्ट मतलब आप यहां
पे ना हाइन हाई फन इवेल करके यहां पे आप
डबल कोड के अंदर में पूरा का पूरा एक
पाइथन कोड भी आप यहां पे लिख सकते हैं कुछ
इस तरीके से ये डेवलप्ड है एसक्यूएल मैप
टूल बहुत एडवांस टूल है इसलिए मैंने आपको
बोला था अब आते हैं यहां पे ऑप्टिमाइजेशन
ऑप्शंस मतलब अब आप जो है ऐसे ऑप्शन जिनको
यूज करके आप एसक्यूएल मैप के परफॉर्मेंस
को ऑप्टिमाइज कर सकते हैं अंशुल राज अब आप
मैसेज मत करो आपका ऑलरेडी आंसर मिल चुका
है नहीं तो आपको सीधा-सीधा क्या करना
पड़ेगा टाइम आउट करना पड़ेगा हां तो
ऑप्टिमाइज कैसे कर सकते हैं अब जैसे हान o
लगा देते हैं टर्न ऑन ऑल ऑप्टिमाइजेशन
स्विचस जितने भी ऑप्टिमाइजेशन स्विचेबल कर
देगा प्रिडिक्ट आउटपुट ये सब है कीप अलाइव
यूज पर्सिस एट एसटीटीपी कनेक्शन तो कीप
अलाइव आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं नल कनेक्शन
यानी ट्राइव पेजेस लेंथ विदाउट एक्चुअल
एसटीडीपी रिस्पांस बॉडी ठीक है तो नल
कनेक्शन थ्रेड्स मैक्स नंबर ऑफ कंक्रेंस
एसटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट डिफॉल्ट वन होता है
यहां पे आप इसको बढ़ा सकते हैं थ्रेड्स को
ठीक है नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स बढ़ा सकते हैं तो
यहां पे जो हमारे लिए यूज़फुल होगा वो कीप
अलाइव होगा एक बार न o को आप लगा सकते हैं
सारे ऑन करने के लिए अदर वाइज आप सिर्फ
कीप अलाइव अ थ्रेड को यूज कर सकते मोस्ट
ऑफ द टाइम ठीक है अब आते य पर इंजेक्शन प
कि भैया
इंजेक्शन जो ऑप्शन है उसको यूज करने का
दिस ऑप्शन कैन बी यूज टू स्पेसिफाई च
पार्ट च पैरामीटर टू टेस्ट फॉर प्रोवाइड
कस्टम इंजेक्शन पेलोड्स एंड ऑप्शन
टैंपरिंग ऑप्शनल टैंपरिंग स्क्रिप्ट्स
चलिए य बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
है अब यहां पे इंजेक्शन में पहला आप हाइन
प दे सकते हैं हाइन प किस लिए होगा
टेस्टेबल पैरामीटर कोई पैरामीटर आपको
डिफाइन करनी है टेस्ट करने के लिए तो आप
हान प का यूज करके पैरामीटर जो है ना वह
आप डिफाइन कर सकते हैं पैरामीटर जो है
वहां पे डाल सकते हैं पर्टिकुलर पैरामीटर
को टेस्ट करने के लिए हाइन हान स्किप लगा
सकते हैं स्किप टेस्टिंग फॉर गिवन
पैरामीटर कोई एक पैरामीटर को टेस्ट स्किप
करना चाहते हैं तो स्किप ये वाला करा सकते
हैं उसके बाद यहां पे हाइफान आईन डीबीएमएस
फोर्स बैक एंड डीबीएमएस टू प्रोवाइड टू
प्रोवाइडेड वैल्यू अब यहां पे ना आप
डीबीएमएस यानी कि डेटाबेस मैनेजमेंट
सिस्टम स्पेसिफिक मेंशन कर सकते हैं जैसे
अब बाय डिफॉल्ट जो भी आप यहां पर डालेंगे
तो नमरे करता है हान एफन डीबीएस ऑप्शन एक
होती है इसके अंदर में उससे डेटाबेस
न्यूमरेशन होती है बट अगर आपको पता है कि
नहीं भाई डेटाबेस वही होगी जैसे कि माय
एसक्यूएल तो आप लगा सकते हैं हाईफा डीब एम
इ माय ए कएल या एमएस एस कएल ऐसे लगा के आप
पर्टिकुलर स्पेसिफिक डेटाबेस बता सकते हैं
उसके बाद आता है हान ओस ओस के बारे में
बता सकते हैं देन आपका जो एक इंपॉर्टेंट
होता है नफन नो कास्ट अब टर्न ऑफ पेलोड
कास्टिंग मैकेनिज्म इसको आप हो सकता है
इनेबल करके रख सकते हैं इफ यू वांट इसके
बारे में जानेंगे डिटेल में एक्चुअली ये
क्या होता है पहले हम सिर्फ ऑप्शंस को जान
रहे हैं ठीक है टेंपर अब यहां पे हाइफान
एफन टेंपर अब ये टेंपर क्या करता है यूज
गिवन स्क्रिप्ट्स फॉर टेंपरिंग इंजेक्शन
डाटा अब ये एक तरह का ना स्क्रिप्ट एक
होता है टैंपर जो होते हैं आपको यहां पे
जो मिल रहे हैं गाइस वो टेंपर स्क्रिप्ट्स
होते हैं जो कि आपके एसक्यूएल मैप के अंदर
प्री डिफाइंड आते हैं एक सेट ऑफ
स्क्रिप्ट्स होते हैं जिनका यूज करके आप
कुछ स्पेसिफिक टास्क करते हो पर्टिकुलर
टास्क जैसे मड सिक्योरिटी को लेके करना हो
जैसे कोई वफ को लेके करना हो वफ बायपास से
लेके करना हो या कुछ अलग-अलग कॉमा लिमिट
को लेके करना हो अलग-अलग चीजें हैं या ऑफ
फस्शन से रिलेटेड कुछ चीजें करनी हो तो वो
काम आप कर सकते हो ऑफ फस्क शंस कर सकते हो
ठीक है वफ बायपास के रिलेटेड कुछ चीजें कर
सकते हो तो टेंपर स्क्रिप्ट्स उस चीज में
काफी ज्यादा हेल्पफुल होती है अब आ जाते
है डिटेक्शन टेक्निक में अब दीज ऑप्शंस
कैन बी यूज टू कस्टमाइज द डिटेक्शन फेज ऑफ
एसक्यूएल मैप चलिए तो हाइफ एफन लेवल तो
लेवल ऑफ टेस्ट टू परफॉर्म तो हमेशा जो एक
अच्छी चीज होती है वो होती है कि आप लेवल
को हमेशा हाईएस्ट लेवल ऑफ टेस्टिंग पे रखो
ज्यादा बढ़िया रहता है एंड हाईएस्ट लेवल
ऑफ रिस्क पे रखो 25 एंड 3 पे ठीक है देन
उसके बाद आप इसमें और भी चीजें हैं यूज़
कर सकते हो कुछ खास नहीं है टेक्निक्स दिस
कैन बी ऑप्शन यूज्ड टू टविक टेस्ट
टेस्टिंग ऑफ स्पेसिफिक एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन
टेक्निक्स अब यहां पे टेक्निक्स आप मेंशन
कर सकते हो जैसे कि हाई फन एफन टेक्निक ये
कीवर्ड लगा सकते हो एंड यहां पे आप
टेक्निक को बता सकते हो और जो इसका कॉमन
टेक्निक है ना वो है बी य एसटी क ये है
लाइक बुलियन अ एरर वगैरह जो होती है
यूनियन बेस्ट वगैरह ये सारी टेक्निक्स हैं
ये शॉर्ट फॉर्म है बीई यू एस टी क्य ये भी
हम देखेंगे अभी थोड़ी देर में कौन-कौन से
टेक्निक्स हैं तो आप टेक्निक्स का यूज कर
सकते हो देन यहां पे टाइम सेकंड ये काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है सेकंड्स टू डिले द
डीबीएमएस रिस्पांस तो आप ये थोड़ा सा डिले
डाल सकते हो कि कितने डिले आपको डालने हैं
डिफॉल्ट फाइव ऑलरेडी होता है तो आप चाहे
तो इसको यूज़ कर लीजिए तो ज्यादा अच्छा
होता है एक
रिकमेंडेटरी करते हैं तो आपको एक अच्छा
रिजल्ट मिलने का चांस जो है वो होता है
ठीक है उसके बाद और ऑप्शंस यहां पे आप
देखिएगा फिर फिंगर प्रिंटिंग की आती है
अगर आपको फिंगरप्रिंटिंग करनी है हान ए से
जो कि कुछ खास यूज नहीं करेंगे अपन नमरे
यहां पे इनमेट करने के लिए तो आप सिंपल सा
फंडा है हान a लगा दीजिएगा एवरीथिंग
रिट्रांसमिट इव ये
करेगा ठीक है देन यहां पे हाइफान आईन
डीबीएस इनमेट डेटाबेस डेटा बेसेस जो
डीबीएमएस डेटाबेस है उसको इनमेट करेगा
हाइफान हा फन टेबल्स टेबल्स को इनमेट
करेगा कॉलम्स कॉलम्स को नरेट करेगा डंप
डेटाबेस के टेबल के एंट्रेस को डंप करेगा
या जो भी डाटा है ना एक्चुअल डाटा है उसको
वह आपके सामने लाकर रखेगा ठीक है तो यह
डंप करेगा ओके यहां पे कमेंट्स चेक फॉर
डीबीएस कमेंट ड्यूरिंग न्यूमरेशन अगर कोई
कमेंट्स आप देखना चाहते हैं लाक कई लोग कई
डेवलपर्स होते हैं ना यार कि कमेंट्स के
अंदर ना कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीज लिख देते हैं
कमेंट्स देखके तो कमेंट्स को पढ़ना है अगर
तो आप यह यूज कर सकते हैं उसी तरह हाइन डी
है डेटाबेस टू इनमेट जो डेटाबेस को इनमेट
करना है वो है हाइन टी है टेबल्स को नरेट
करने के लिए हाफ सी है कॉलम्स को नरेट
करने के लिए ठीक है एंड हान य है यूजर्स
को नरेट करने के लिए तो ये ऑप्शंस है यहां
पे जो आप इसको यूज कर सकते हैं चलिए अब
यहां पे नीचे आते हैं यहां पे ब्रूट फोर्स
में हमें कोई खास यूज नहीं है अभी फिलहाल
के लिए फाइल सिस्टम में कुछ खास यूज है
नहीं ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में आप चाहे तो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का पता लगाना चाहे तो आप
कर सकते हैं या प्रोमट फॉर इंटरेक्ट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम शेल अगर आपको लाना है
एग्जीक्यूट करना है तो शेल का यूज कर सकते
हैं उसके बाद विंडोज रजिस्ट्री प्रोसेस है
कुछ आप यूज करना चाहे तो कर सकते हैं या
एक और जनरल ऑप्शंस है जिसमें कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें हैं जैसे कि यहां पे
हान न बैच बैच ना व्हाट इज दिस बैच नेवर
आस्क यूजर इनपुट यूज द डिफॉल्ट बिहेवियर
मतलब एएल मैप को जब आप यूज करेंगे तो
बीच-बीच में आपसे कुछ-कुछ क्वेश्चंस करेगा
ये कि ये पर्टिकुलर यूज करना है क्या ये
पीएचपी सेशन आईडी मिली है है इसी को साथ
कंटिन्यू करना है यस नो तो भाई बैच लगा दो
सब खत्म कुछ नहीं यूज़ में आएगा मतलब सब
यह ऑटोमेटिक डिफॉल्ट वाला जो होगा वो इसी
को यूज़ करेगा अच्छी चीज है ये ठीक है
उसके बाद यहां पे क्लीन अप है क्लीन अप द
डीबीएमएस फ्रॉम एसक्यूएल मैप स्पेसिफिक
यूडीएफ एंड टेबल्स तो डेटाबेस को यह क्लीन
अप करने के लिए होता है और कुछ नहीं है न
नथिंग एल्स ठीक है उसके बाद नीचे आ जाएंगे
फ्लश सेशन फ्लश स्टेशन फाइल्स एंड फॉर
करंट टारगेट करंट टारगेट के लिए जो भी
सेशन फाइल्स हैं जो सेव्ड है आपके लाइक जब
आप एल इंजेक्शन एक बार चलाते हो तो जो भी
रिजल्ट आता है वो एक सेशन फाइल के अंदर
क्या होता है ना कि स्टोर हो जाता है
नेक्स्ट टाइम जब आप चलाओगे ना सेम अगर
टारगेट पे तो उसी से वो
रिट्रिक्स जो है वो यूज में आता है ठीक है
उसके बाद यहां पे फ्रेश क्वेरीज है इग्नोर
क्वेरीज क्वेरी रिजल्ट्स स्टोर्ड इन द
सेशन फाइल जो क्वेरी रिजल्ट सेशन फाइल में
उसको इग्नोर कीजिए और फ्रेश क्वेरीज फिर
से कीजिए यह भी काम आ जाता है आपके ठीक है
उसके बाद यहां पे आते है स्किप वफ स्किप
डिटेक्शन ऑफ वफ या आईपीएस प्रोटेक्शन तो
अगर कोई वफ डिटेक्शन आपको स्किप करना है
तो आप लगाइए अदर वाइज आप मत लगाइए अगर
आपको उसको डिटेक्ट करना है तो ठीक
है
ओके नीचे आते हैं यहां पे अब यहां पर कुछ
मिसलेनियस ऑप्शंस है इसके अंदर में बीप का
ऑप्शन है बीप साउंड के लिए पर्ज का ऑप्शन
है सेफली रिमूव ऑल कंटेंट फ्रॉम एसक्यूएल
डेटा डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
को तो आप अपडेट चला लीजिएगा तो हान आईन जो
है अपडेट से आपका एएल मैप जो है अपडेट हो
जाएगा जैसे अ एल मैप किया हान आईन अपडेट
ये कमांड चलाई तो जो भी आपका एसक्यूएल मैप
है य देख सकते हैं ट्रांग टू फेस द
लेटेस्ट जिप बॉल फ्रॉम द रिपोजिटरी तो मैं
यहां पे यस कर देता हूं एंटर कर देता हूं
तो यह जो आपका एएल मैप जो भी लेटेस्ट
वर्जन में होगा जो भी होगा वो आपको
इंस्टॉल करके यहां पे दे देता है ठीक है
तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे पहले जो एएल
वर्जन था वो मेरा था
1.8.3 स्टेबल वर्जन था बट ये 1.8.6 प 6 डे
वर्जन आ चुका है स्टेबल वर्जन नहीं है बट
ठीक है फिर भी चलेगा अपना कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है अपन यूज कर सकते हैं थोड़ा सा इसमें
प्रॉब्लम आ सकता है स्टेबल वर्जन हमेशा
यूज करना चाहिए काली जो है आपको जब भी कोई
टूल देती है जनरली वो स्टेबल वर्जन ही
देती है ठीक है तो यहां पे आप इसको यूज कर
सकते हैं ओके चलिए अब यहां पे देखते हैं
कुछ चीजें जो बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है हम उसको
देखेंगे बट पहले हम इसको यूज करना शुरू कर
देते हैं फर्स्ट वी विल स्टार्ट यूजिंग
दिस ये ऐड आ गई तो
यस यस
यस या करेक्ट
करेक्ट मैं इतना आराम से थोड़ा एएल मैप को
इतना डिटेल में मैं जानबूझ के बता रहा हूं
गाइस आप लोगों को मुझे पता है आपको भी
हेल्प फाइल देखनी आती है वकी फाइल्स देखनी
आती है सब कुछ आता है बट मैं आपको थोड़ा
समझाना चाहता हूं जो बिगिनर्स हैं उनके
लिए मैं बताना चाहता हूं आई एम नॉट हियर
फॉर एक्सपर्ट्स जो हंटर्स हैं या एक्सपर्ट
जो रिसर्चस हैं या एनालिस्ट्स हैं जो
एक्सपर्ट है काफी ज्यादा बक बाउंटीज में
मैं उनके लिए यहां पे बिल्कुल नहीं हूं ना
ये क्लासेस उनके लिए होती है ये क्लासेस
होती हैं जो बिगिनर्स हैं इस फील्ड में
जिनको कोई रिसोर्स सही से प्रॉपर
स्ट्रक्चर्ड वे में फ्री में अवेलेबल नहीं
है बग बाउंटीज का एंड दे वांट टू लर्न एंड
दे वांट टू अर्न क्योंकि ये टॉपिक मैंने
अब देखो मैं बहुत सारी टॉपिक्स चूज कर
सकता था अ साइबर सिक्योरिटी के अंदर में
जिस पे मैं आपको पढ़ाता मतलब मैं आपको एक
सच्चाई बता देता हूं मैं बहुत सारे
टॉपिक्स चूज कर सकता था साइबर सिक्योरिटी
डोमेन के अंदर में जिस पे मैं आपको फ्री
क्लासेस देता मेरे पास फिर भी व्यूज आते
सब्सक्राइबर आते सब कुछ आता
google2 अर्निंग आप जल्दी नहीं कर पाएंगे
आपको जॉब करनी पड़ेगी फ्रीलांस प्रोजेक्ट
उठाना पड़ेगा इसमें तो आप खुद के मालिक
खुद ही हैं भाई अगर आपको बाउंटीज लगनी
शुरू हो गई एक दो बाउंटीज लग गई तो आपके
अंदर जो अंदर से एक विश्वास उठके निकलेगा
ना एक खुद पे जो भरोसा होगा और जो
इनकरेजमेंट आएगी वो नेक्स्ट लेवल की आने
वाली है तो जब तक नहीं हो रहा है तब तक
नहीं हो रहा है जब होने लगेगा तो छप्पर
फार के होने लगेगा ठीक है ट्स
इट
ओके मजे आ रहे हैं चलो
बढ़िया हेलो हेलो विनय
[संगीत]
महेंद्रे हां कर सकते हो निशा कोई निशा कर
सकते हो बिल्कुल कर सकते हो कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है यू कैन डू
इट यहां पे है वन ऑफ द ग्रेटेस्ट मेंटर्स
आई हैव एवर सीन यू आर द ग्रेट सर मुझे
जितना पेंटेस्टिंग आता है उसमें यह
प्लेलिस्ट का बहुत योगदान है थैंक यू वेरी
मच सर शुभम थैंक यू सो मच शुभम फॉर योर
गुड वर्ड्स कीप लर्निंग गाइस कीप लर्निंग
ब्रदर सभी लोग सीखते रहिए बस यही चाहता
हूं मैं फोड़ते रही है चलिए तो यहां पे
टारगेट ले लेते हैं टारगेट हमारा आपको पता
ही है कौन सा टारगेट है भाई ये तो पता ही
है एसक्यूएल मैप हाइन यू यूआरएल देते हैं
यहां पे एंड यहां पे अपना टारगेट मेंशन कर
देते हैं ये कौन सा टारगेट आ
गया इसको हटाओ जो टारगेट था हमारा ना उस
टारगेट को एक बार ट्राई करते हैं यूज करने
का ये वाली कैट वाली ठीक
है तो हमने टारगेट दे दिया यहां
पे डबल कोड के अंदर हमने दिया अब यहां पे
हमें ना नमरे करना है भैया क्या इनमेट
करना है तो हमें डीबी डीबीएस डेटाबेस
इनमेट करनी है तो उसके लिए कौन सा कमांड
आप यूज करेंगे हान न डीबीएस देखो यहां पे
कहीं पे मिलेगा तुम्हें यहां पे कहां गए
हो भाई हान न डीबीएस ये रहा हाईफा आईन
डीबीएस इनमेट डीबीएमएस डेटा बेसेस तो हम
डेटा बेसेस इनमेट करेंगे तो हाइफान आईन
डीबीएस अब जब हाईफा आईन डीबीएस हमने लगा
दिया अब इसके बाद जो है चीजें आती हैं
ऑप्शंस जो हमें यूज करना है वह ऑप्शंस आते
हैं तो भैया अब ऑप्शंस कौन सा यूज करें तो
सबसे पहला जो ऑप्शन यूज करेंगे नफन रैंडम
एजेंट ताकि रैंडम एजेंट्स को ब्राउजर
एजेंट्स को यूज किया करें तो हमने रैंडम
एजेंट्स वाली चीज लगा दी चलिए अब हम क्या
कर देते हैं टारगेट तो हमने दे दिया
रिक्वेस्ट वाली चीज में यहां पे हम यहां
पे अब कुछ अलग-अलग डिफरेंट चीजें डालेंगे
जैसे कि पहले हमने क्या किया रैंडम एजेंट
डाल दिया अच्छी बात है कुछ और डालना है
क्या इसमें देख लीजिए लोड लाइव कुकीज कुकी
कुछ नहीं डालना डाटा नहीं डालना क्योंकि
हमने टारगेट को ऐड किया है रेफर हेडर
वगैरह नहीं डालनी टर को यूज हम नहीं
करेंगे वेफ बा वेफ चेकिंग नहीं स्किप
स्किप वफ चेकिंग नहीं हम वफ चेक कर लेंगे
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अ नथिंग एल्स हियर कुछ
और कुछ खास है नहीं यहां पे हां कीप अलाइव
ऑप्टिमाइजेशन अब हम करेंगे कीप अलाइव
लगाएंगे हाइफान आई फन कीप सॉरी कीप अलाइव
तो यह हमने एक ऑप्टिमाइजेशन यूज किया कीप
अलाइव और थ्रेड्स हां जी थ्रेड्स देंगे हम
तो हाइन हाइन टी एच आर ई ए डी एस थ्रेड्स
इज इक्वल टू डिफॉल्ट वन होता है हम यहां
पे 10 देंगे हाइफान ए1 थ्रेड्स देंगे 10
नहीं देंगे चलो फाइव ही देंगे डिफॉल्ट वन
है ना तो हम फाइव देते हैं थोड़ा सा बढ़ा
देते हैं हाफ ए1 थ्रेड्स बढ़ा देते हैं अब
आ जाते हैं यहां पे इंजेक्शन के ऊपर में
अब इंजेक्शन कौन-कौन सी करते हैं तो चलिए
भैया कोई टेस्टेबल पैरामीटर है और नहीं
नहीं है तो छोड़ देते हैं डीबीएमएस तो
हमने डीबीएस कर ही दिया तो हमें ये डिफाइन
करने की जरूरत नहीं है बाकी कुछ और हमें
यहां पे कुछ यूज नहीं करना है टर्न ऑफ
पेलोड कास्टिंग मैकेनिज्म तो नो कास्ट हम
कर देते हैं अब देखो यहां पे नो कास्ट का
मतलब यहां पे क्या हो जाता है मैं आपको
बता देता हूं पहले हम इसको मेंशन कर देते
हैं नफन नो हाइन कास्ट ठीक है हमने ये कर
दिया अब देखो यहां पर मैं य सर्च करता हूं
नफन नो हाइन कास्ट ठीक है य हमने किया
नेक्स्ट पर चलते हैं देखो टन ऑफ पेलोड
कास्टिंग मैकेनिज्म इसका मतलब क्या होता
है इस चीज को थोड़ा समझो न रिट्रीविंग
रिजल्ट जब एसकल मैप आपके रिजल्ट्स को
रिट्रीव करता है य एक मैकेनिज्म को यूज
करता है र ल द एंट्रीज आर बींग कास्ट टू अ
स्ट्रिंग टाइप जितने भी आपके एंट्रीज होते
हैं ना वो स्ट्रिंग टाइप में कास्ट होते
हैं एंड रिप्लेस विथ अ वाइट स्पेस
कैरेक्टर इन केस ऑफ नल
वैल्यूज नल वैल्यूज अगर कोई होती है तो
उसको रिप्लेस किया जाता है एक वाइट स्पेस
कैरेक्टर से दैट इज बीइंग मेड टू प्रिवेंट
एनी एरर नियस स्टेट्स कोई एरर नियस स्टेट
से बचाने के लिए कोई एरर नियस मतलब एरर
वाली स्टेट से बचाने के लिए एंड टू इजी द
डेटा रिटेबल प्रोसेस इट सेल्फ ताकि डटा
रिटेबल का प्रोसेस जो है वो इजी हो पाए
नेवर द लेस देयर आर रिपोर्टेड केसेस ओल्डर
वर्जन ऑफ मायकल डेडी बीएमएस
वेयर दिस मैकेनिज्म नीडेड टू बी टर्न ऑफ
कुछ ओल्डर डीबीएमएस वर्जंस में यह
मैकेनिज्म जो है इसको बंद करने का एक
रिकमेंडेशन दिया गया है एंड इसको बंद कर
देना चाहिए ऐसा पाया गया बिकॉज बाय यूजिंग
दिस स्विच बिक ऑफ द प्रॉब्लम्स विद द डेटा
ट्रेवल ठीक है क्योंकि डेटा रिटेबल के
प्रॉब्लम्स के साथ इसलिए हम इसको यूज कर
रहे हैं ताकि हमें कोई प्रॉब्लम कोई मतलब
ही ना हो नो कास्ट को यूज कीजिए और बाकी
चीजें गई साइड में इसको हटा ही देते हैं
ठीक है
भैया तो चलिए हमने अब क्या किया यहां पे
डिटेक्शन में यहां
पे इंजेक्शन इंजेक्शन का यूज हमने कर लिया
कर रहे थे नो कास्ट तो हमने यहां से नो
कास्ट उठा लिया नो स्केप भी हम लगा सकते
हैं इफ यू वांट फिलहाल इसके लिए जरूरी
नहीं है अब यहां पर आते हैं हाइन हान
टेंपर जो कि काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है टेंपर
स्क्रिप्ट का यूज करना नफन टेंपर टेंपर
स्क्रिप्ट का यूज करना अब देखो यहां प टपर
स्क्रिप्ट क्या है मैं आपको यह दिखाता हूं
देखो एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन के एसक्यूएल मैप
के अंदर ना टेंपर स्क्रिप्ट एक आपकी आती
है जो आपके एसक्यूएल के फोल्डर में आपको
मिल जाएगा अब मुझे यह बताओ मुझे एसक्यूएल
मैप के जितने भी डायरेक्टरी है वो फाइंड
करना है कैसे फाइंड करूंगा मुझे आप लोग
चैट में बताओ मुझे एसक्यूएल मैप के तने
भी डायरेक्टरी है कि कहां कहां पर वह
फाइंड लोकेटेड है वह मुझे फाइंड करना है
मैं
क्या सर्च
करूंगा
बताइए नहीं कमांड बता दिया ना मुझे एसकल
मैप की डायरेक्टरी खोजनी है लोकेट लोकेट
एसकल मैप ना चलो देख लेते हैं लोकेट एसकल
मैप यह तो पूरी की पूरी पता नहीं क्याक आ
गई यार सारी फाइल्स एंड ल सब आ गई मुझे
पर्टिकुलर सिर्फ एसकल मैप वाली डायरेक्ट
चाहिए चलिए वेर इज वेयर इज एसक्यूएल मैप
यह कमांड यूज कर लेते हैं तो यहां पर आपको
एसक्यूएल मैप वाली जो लोकेशन है वह आ गई
बिल्कुल परफेक्ट बिल्कुल परफेक्ट ठीक है
बढ़िया वेर ज वाली कौन किसने बताया हैक
स्किस सही है बिल्कुल सही है लोकेट का यूज
आप देखो लोकेट का यूज आप कर सकते हो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है यू कैन यूज द लोकेट बट
वो सारी जो रिलेटेड फाइल्स लोकेशन सब दे
देती है नॉट स्पेसिफिक वन तो आप वेरीज का
यूज भी कर सकते हैं इफ यू वांट वेर यू कैन
यूज द वेरीज ठीक है लेकिन इसके अलावा एक
और कमांड है जो कि है फाइंड
कमांड फाइंड कमांड के बारे में किसकिस को
पता है मुझे बताइए लेट मी
नो हु नोज अबाउट द फाइंड
कमांड
बताइए और किनको किनको नहीं पता जिनको नहीं
पता व भी बताइए पता है उनको वो भी
बताइए ओ ग चलो ठीक है काफी सारे लोगों को
पता है
अगर
आपने लिनिक्स वाली सीरीज जो है ना काली
लिनिक्स की हमारे डेनिक्स अकेडमी
है उसी में फाइंड करना है बट अगर आपको
स्पेसिफिक डायरेक्टरी मेंशन करनी है तो आप
वो मेंशन कर सकते मैंने जैसे यहां पर फाइल
सिस्टम स्लैश दे दिया अब तो स्लैश के अंदर
तो पूरा लिनिक्स सिस्टम ही होता है तो
बेसिकली आपने पूरे लिनिक्स सिस्टम अपने
पूरे फाइल सिस्टम में यह सर्च कर रहे हैं
तो हमने फाइंड स्पेस स्लश दे दिया अब यहां
प देने के बाद अब यहां पे यहां स्विच यूज
करेंगे हाइन
टाइप भैया टाइप कौन सा टाइप है इसको जिसको
आप सर्च करना सकते हैं तो अगर आप फाइल
सर्च करना चाहते हैं तो यहां पे एफ लिख
दीजिएगा अगर आप डायरेक्टरी सर्च करना
चाहते हैं तो डी लिख
दीजिएगा अब यहां पे हान नेम यानी कि कौन
सा नाम है जिसको आप सर्च करना चाहते हैं
तो मुझे एसक्यूएल मैप चाहिए तो मैंने
एसक्यूएल मैप लिखा और मैं एंटर करूंगा तो
ये क्या करेगा एसक्यूएल मैप से रिलेटेड
जितनी भी डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
दिस कमांड समझ में आया सब लोगों को एवरीवन
गॉट आर यू ग्रेट सर पूछ रहे हो कि बता रहे
हो भाई एवरीवन गॉट समझ में आ
गया निकल के ठीक है तो फाइंड कमांड का यूज
कीजिएगा ज्यादा बढ़िया मतलब अच्छा अच्छा
एक कमांड है आपके लिए यू कैन यूज दिस
पर्टिकुलर
कमांड अब एसक्यूएल मैप का जो लोकेशन है वो
है टीसी एसक्यूएल मैप यहां पे एंड यहां पे
यूएसआर शेयर के अंदर तो हम क्या करते हैं
सीडी स् एसआर इसके लोकेशन पे चलते हैं
सॉरी स्ल शेयर एंड यहां पे सीडी स् एएल
मैप इसमें चलते हैं एलस करोगे तो आपके
इसके अंदर की सारी फाइल्स वगैरह जो है वो
दिखनी स्टार्ट हो जाएंगी और इसी के अंदर
मैं आपको एक डायरेक्टरी दिखेगी टपर नाम से
डायरेक्टरी दिखेगी टेंपर नाम से अब ये
कैसे एलएस आईन ए करते हैं एलएस आफ एल करते
हैं तो जब आप एलएस हाफ एल करेंगे तो आप
देख सकते हैं कि कौन-कौन सी डायरेक्टरी है
कौन-कौन सी फाइल्स है ये आपको पता हो जानी
चाहिए इससे कैसे पता चलती आप सबको पता ही
है भैया कि जब आप इसकी परमिशन चेक कर रहे
हैं परमिशन के थ्रू भी आप पता लगा सकते
हैं तो जब ये डी से स्टार्ट हो रही है तो
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री है यहां पे यहां पे
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
है तो चलिए टैंपर नाम की डायरेक्टरी में
चलते हैं सीडी टैंपर एंड यहां पे एलएस
करते हैं जब आप एलएस करेंगे तो आपको
अलग-अलग यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट्स दिखने को
मिलेगी पाइथन स्क्रिप्ट क्योंकि एएल मैप
मिलेंगे मेट स्प्ड क्योंकि रूबी में बना
हुआ है या पोर्ट हुआ है तो आपको वहां के
मेट स्प्ड के जो स्क्रिप्ट्स है वो जनरली
मोस्टली रूबी में ही देखने को मिलेंगे या
कुछ पर्ल्स में पर्ल में भी आपको देखने को
मिल जाएगा तो आपको यहां पे ये अलग-अलग
क्या मिल रहे हैं टैम परर स्क्रिप्ट्स मिल
रहे हैं जिससे कि आप क्या कर सकते हैं
एसक्यूएल एसक्यूएल मैप के साथ क्या कर
सकते हैं
इंजेक्शन इंजेक्शन के मेथड्स को इंजेक्शन
के पेलेट्स को डिफाइन कर सकते हैं किस
टाइप के इंजेक्शन है किस टाइप के इंजेक्शन
करनी है आपको तो भैया हम टेंपर से डिफाइन
करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको अलग-अलग इंजेक्शन
के पेलोड्स मिल रहे
हैं ठीक है गॉट
इट आई एम फॉलोइंग दिस सीरीज सिंस डेज एंड
ऑलरेडी फिनिश जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल हंटिंग
वीडियो थैंक यू सर फॉर ऑल द वैल्यू यू आर
वेलकम ब्रदर दोस्तों के बीच
फैलाइला सेस के बारे में ताकि वो भी कुछ
फायदा उठा पाए इसका तो यहां पे टेंपर
स्क्रिप्ट्स है जिसको हम यूज़ करेंगे अब
देखो यहां पे जैसे ये बहुत सारे हैं यहां
पे एंड नल ए एंड नल बाइट अ यहां पे बाइनरी
ब्लू कोट ठीक है देयर आर मल्टीपल डी
यूनियन ठीक है इक्वल टू लाइक अलग-अलग
ग्रेटेस्ट ड पीआई मोड सिक्योरिटी वर्जन ये
काफी पॉपुलर है मोड सिक्योरिटी वर्जन वाली
ठीक है मोड मोड सिक्योरिटी जीरो वर्जन
यहां पे यहां पे मल्टीपल स्पेसेस डॉट
मल्टीपल स्पेसेस यहां पे यहां पे आपका आई
टू केस इफ टू केस जिसको हम बोलते हैं
बेसिकली he2 कक्टर एकट कैरेक्टर के लिए
होता है यहां पे स्पेस टू कमेंट यहां पे
जैसे कोई स्पेस है तो लाइक कमेंट करने के
लिए तो स्पेस कमेंट की यूज के लिए है अपर
केस के लिए यहां पे ये है फॉरवर्ड एक्स
फॉरवर्ड फॉर डिफाइन करने के लिए ये यहां
पे है ठीक है तो देयर आर मल्टीपल टेंपर
स्क्रिप्ट दैट वी कैन यूज ठीक है तो हम
यहां पे कुछ टेंपर स्क्रिप्ट्स का भी यूज
करेंगे तो फिलहाल के लिए हाईफा आई फन
टेंपर देते हैं एंड यहां इक्वल दे देते
हैं आई थिंक यही है हाईफा इन टैंपर इज
इक्वल टू टैंपर स्क्रिप्ट्स यूज द गिवन
स्क्रिप्ट्स तो चलिए स्क्रिप्ट यहां पर
मेंशन कर देते हैं तो एक जो स्क्रिप्ट हम
यूज करने वाले हैं वह है मड सिक्योरिटी
वर्जन इसको यूज करने वाले हैं मोड
सिक्योरिटी मोड सिक्योरिटी एक तरह का
सिक्योरिटी है वफ सिक्योरिटी है जिसके लिए
हम यह यूज कर रहे हैं पर्टिकुलर पेलोड को
जिससे कि हम ट्राई करेंगे बायपास करने का
ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है तो हमने यह यूज
कर लिया कॉमा
देंगे और भी यहां पे यूज कर लेते
हैं
अ कौन सा यूज करें स्पेस टू कमेंट यूज कर
लेते हैं एक
बार स्पेस टू कमेंट याद रखिएगा आपको डॉट
पवा एक्सटेंशन नहीं देना है सिर्फ आपको
नाम लिखना है स्पेस टू कमेंट हमने यूज कर
लिया अ ट्स ग्रेट ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके और
भी चीज आप कॉमा लेस लिमिट भी यूज कर सकते
हैं बहुत सारी चीजें वो कर सकते हैं चलो
हम फिलहाल के लिए दो रखते हैं ठीक है तो
हमने क्या किया यहां पे हमने टैंपर
स्क्रिप्ट्स को यूज कर लिया चलिए बढ़िया
अब यहां पे नीचे आते हैं टेक्निक्स में अब
टेक्निक्स जो है ना यहां पे हाईफा ई फन
टेक्निक अब इसको आप थोड़ा सा समझिए ये
क्या है ये कुछ भी नहीं है गाइ इसका यूज
आप कर भी सकते हैं नहीं भी कर सकते हैं
आपके ऊपर अ आपके ऊपर है ये तो मैं यहां पे
टेक्निक्स दिखाता हूं यहां पे हाईफा नफ
टेक्निक्स ये क्या करते हैं इनका जो
डिफॉल्ट टेक्निक्स होता है वो होता है बी
यूएसटी क्य बीई यूएसटी कू जो कि होता है
बुलियन बेस्ड ब्लाइंड बेस्ड बुलियन
ब्लाइंड एरर यूनियन टाइम बेस्ट ये सारे जो
एल इंजेक्शन के टेक्निक्स है ना वही है और
कुछ भी नहीं है तो अगर आप इसको देना चाहे
तो आप दे सकते हैं नहीं देना चाहे नहीं दे
सकते हैं क्योंकि डिफॉल्ट जो है इसका
ऑलरेडी बीई यूएसटी क्य ही होता है तो
जरूरत नहीं है आपको यहां पे मेंशन करने की
मैं ये बोल रहा हूं ठीक है तो टेक्निक को
मेंशन करने की जरूरत नहीं है टाइम सेकंड
को आप मेंशन कर सकते हैं अगर जरूरत पड़ती
है तो अगर अभी फिलहाल बिना इसके ही देख के
देख लेते हैं चलते हैं अब यहां पे है हान
एफन डीबीएस तो हमने मेंशन कर ही दिया है
डेटाबेस चाहिए हमें भैया और तो कुछ यहां
पे हमें देखने को कुछ मिल नहीं
रहा जिसको हम यूज करने वाले हैं ठीक है
नथिंग
एल्स ओके ओके ओके और कुछ देख लेते
हैं सेशन फाइल लोड फ्रॉम सेशन फाइल नहीं
चाहिए फ्लश सेशन कर सकते हैं सेशन को फ्लश
करना हो तो फनन फ्लश सेशन सेशन फ्लश हो
जाएगा और कुछ भी नहीं है तो चलो लगा देते
हैं हान फ्लस सेशन न्यू सेशन इस टाइम आपकी
जनरेट होगी फ्लश सेशन लगा देते हैं तो
फ्रेश क्वेरीज वही है फ्रेश क्वेरीज के
लिए होता है और कुछ नहीं है तो हान एफन
फ्रेश क्वेरीज जो है आप इसको यूज कर सकते
हैं हान एफन फ्रेश क्वेरीज हाइन आईन फ्रेश
क्यू यू ई आर आई एस क्यू यू ई आर आई ए एस
आप इसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं देन लेट्स गो
टू अदर ऑप्शंस हियर स्किप वफ का अगर करना
चाहे तो कर लीजिए फिलहाल के लिए कोई जरूरत
है नहीं यहां पे मिसलेनियस में यहां पे
आपको लिस्ट टेंपर्स टेंपर्स लिस्ट लिस्ट
टेंपर्स भाई टेंपर्स की वो लिस्ट करने के
लिए टपर स्क्रिप्ट्स को और कुछ तो यहां पे
फिलहाल नहीं मुझे मिल रहा है अब यह तो
आपने लगा दिया अब इसके अलावा कुछ और भी
चीजें हैं गाइस कुछ और ऑप्शंस है जो आप
लगा सकते हैं हमने टैंपर तो लगा दिया भैया
हमने हमने यहां पे कुछ चीजें जो है वो यूज
करनी है चलिए ऊपर चलते हैं ऊपर में चलके
देखते हैं यहां
पे और ये लेवल डिटेक्शन लेवल तो दज ऑप्शन
कैन बी यूज टू कस्टमाइज द डिटेक्शन फेस तो
लेवल और रिस्क ये यूज कर सकते हैं बट
फिलहाल के लिए ना हम क्या करते हैं हम
बिना किसी पर्टिकुलर चीजों के बिना किसी
अदर ऑप्शंस के इसको एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं
देखते हैं क्या होता है ठीक है और ऑप्शंस
कुछ हम यूज नहीं करते हैं फिलहाल के लिए
मैं बस रैंडम एजेंट यूज किया है कीप अलाइव
यूज किया थ्रेड्स को यूज किया है नो कास्ट
किया है टम परर स्क्रिप्ट यूज किया फ्लश
एशन किया है ट्स इट इतना ही किया है और अब
हम एंटर करते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इज द
हैपनिंग चलो ये स्कल मैप स्टार्ट हो गया
नाउ इट्स ट्रांग
अब देखो यहां पे देखो यहां अब यहां पर
क्या हो रहा है हमने यहां पर नो कास्ट यूज
किया अब हमने ना यहां पे बैच यूज नहीं
किया बैच का मतलब क्या था देख लीजिए हाई
फनन बैच हान आईन बैच यह देखिए बैच का मतलब
था नेवर आस्क फॉर यूजर इनपुट यूज द
डिफॉल्ट बिहेवियर तो हमने यहां पे बैच
यहां लगाया नहीं इस कमांड में तो यहां प
हमसे अय पूछ रहा है इट लुक लाइक द बैक एंड
डीबीएमएस ड यू वांट टू स्किप द टेस्ट पलट
फॉर द स्पेसिफिक डीवीएस तो ओबवियस है यहां
पर डिफॉल्ट यस होगा कि स्किप ही कर देना
है तो बट यहां पर पूछ रहा है आपसे अगली
बार यह नहीं पूछेगा देखो मैं इसको कैंसिल
करता हूं सेम कमांड में यहां पे यहां पर
हाई फन हाई फन बैच लगा देता हूं अब देखो
यह आपसे पूछेगा ही नहीं कुछ यह खुद ही
करेगा जो डिफॉल्ट है वही देखो यहां पर
डिफॉल्ट आ गया ना यस खुद ही इसने यस टाइप
कर दिया वा टाइप कर दिया ठीक है नाउ लेट्स
वेट अब यहां पे ना इसके जो आउटपुट्स है
उसको देख के शायद आपको कुछ
कुछ फैमिलियर लग रहा होगा कुछ कुछ चीजें
गेट पैरामीटर कैट मा स्कल एरर बेस हैविंग
ऑर्डर बाय इंजेक्टबल ये बोल रहा है कि
भैया य इंजेक्टबल है तो चलिए अच्छी बात है
इंजेक्टबल है तो गेट अपर्स टू मस्कल टाइम
बेस्ड ब्लाइंड इंजेक्टबल अब ये ब्लाइंड
बुलियन वाली जो पेलोड है उसको यूज कर रहा
है अलग-अलग पेलोड यूज कर रहा है आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे एंड यह देखिए इसने क्या
किया हंट किया कमांड से कमांड रन किया एंड
उसके बाद हमें यहां पर रिजल्ट दे दिया अब
ये रिजल्ट इज नॉट इंपोर्टेंट फिलहाल के
लिए
अब ये रिजल्ट इज नॉट इंपॉर्टेंट फिलहाल के
लिए क्या इंपॉर्टेंट है इस रिजल्ट को
समझना टू अंडरस्टैंड दिस रिजल्ट रिजल्ट
में बहुत कुछ मिलाए देखिए ना कितना कुछ
मिला है दिमाग खराब हो जाएगा आपको देख देख
के बट इस रिजल्ट को समझना इज वेरी मच
इंपोर्टेंट अब हमें यहां पर डेटाबेस मिल
चुकी है देखो ना य फेचिंग डेटाबेस नेम्स
अवेलेबल डेटा बेसेस यह एक्यू आर्ट एसी यू
ए आरटी और इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा दो डेटा
बेसेस यहां पर आपके अवेलेबल है तो हमें
मिल चुका डन जब आप बग बाउटी कर रहे हो
होते हैं हंट कर रहे होते हैं किसी
प्रोग्राम पे हंट कर रहे होते हैं आपको
इतना डाटा आपने निकाल के डेटाबेस का नाम
दे दिया ना दिखा दिया डेटाबेस हो गया भाई
और कुछ नहीं करना और यहां पे आपको सिंपल
आपको एक चीज दिख रही होगी यह देखिए
एसक्यूएल मैप
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
पॉइंट इसको मिले हैं और यही इंजेक्शन
पॉइंट जो आपको यहां पे मिल रहा है इसी को
आपको आपके बग बाउंट रिपोर्ट के अंदर मेंशन
करना है जब आप रिपोर्ट क्रिएट करेंगे हैकर
वन पर बग क्राउड प ओपन बग बाउंट प कहीं पर
भी आप रिपोर्ट करेंगे किसी भी बग बांटी
प्लेटफार्म प तो आपको इसी पर्टिकुलर
रिपोर्ट इसी पर्टिकुलर डटा की जरूरत है
बाकी सारे डाटा बेकार है सच बता रहा हूं
बाकी सारे डाटा आपको जरूरत नहीं है नीड
नहीं है आपको कुछ भी बोलने की आपको बस यह
डाटा बताना है तो इस डाटा में क्या
है सर प्लीज रिचार्ज कर दो
वू दूंगा आपको भाई नहीं चाहिए नहीं चाहिए
आपको आपके क्या मोटिवेशन क्यों किस चीज का
रिचार्ज करना यह बताओ यार मतलब क्या
रिचार्ज किस चीज का रिचार्ज करना है बताओ
रिचार्ज करने के लिए बोल रहा है बंदा क
रिचार्ज मतलब क्यों रिचार्ज करनी है यह तो
बताओ यार मेरे से रिचार्ज करवा रहा
है गजब बात है
भाई क्या यार अरे इंटरनेट क्यों रिचार्ज
करनी है मोटिवेशन भाई
और कितने का रिचार्ज होता है तुम्हारा
इंटरनेट का जो तुम मेरे से मतलब ऐसा क्या
रिचार्ज अमाउंट होता है जो मेरे से बोल
रहे
हो सर आई एम टेस्टिंग वेबसाइट एंड आई एम
श्यर इट्स वल्नरेबल टू आरसी बट आई डोंट
हैव एनी वीपीएस टू पिंग इट यूजिंग आरसी ऑन
द वेबसाइट इज देर एनी सर्विस दैट प्रोवाइड
सच फैसिलिटी वीपी अरे तो वीपीएस यूज कर लो
कोई सा भी डिजिटल ओसन का यूज कर लो ना यूज
द डिजिटल ओन वीडियो देखने के लिए कौन सा
मतलब कितने का रिचार्ज होता है भाई वीडियो
देखने के लिए बताओ सच बोल रहे हो झूठ बोल
रहे हो कुछ पता ही नहीं
है अ या कितने का रिचार्ज होता है j का
नंबर है क्या भाई कितने का रिचार्ज होता
है वो वो एक्स्ट्रा पैक जो आता है वो बोल
रहे हो क्या जो एडेड एडिशनल पैक आता
है वीडियो देखने के लिए रिचार्ज करने के
लिए बोल रहा है यार इसलिए मतलब थोड़ा पूछ
ले रहा हूं मतलब डाटा शायद नहीं होगी इसके
पास मे
भी मे भी डाटा नहीं होगी शायद
अच्छा मजाक कर रहे हो अच्छा इतना देर मजाक
किया टाइम वेस्ट कर दिया तुमने ब्रदर मुझे
लगा तुम सीरियस
हो मजाक कर रहे हो चलो तो मैं भी एक मजाक
करता हूं आपके साथ मोटिवेशन ब्रदर जो
रिचार्ज के लिए बोल रहे थे अभी पूछा तो
मैंने मजाक बोल र मजाक कर रहा हूं तो एक
छोटा सा मजाक मेरे साइड से भी जस्ट बहुत
छोटा सा मजाक है प्लीज प्लीज टेक इट प्लीज
टेक इट ठीक है एक छोटा सा मजाक बस छोटा सा
इतना छोटा सा मजाक करना वाला हू बस छोटा
सा बहुत छोटा मजाक है प्लीज प्लीज प्लीज
डोंट डोंट डोंट वरी प्लीज देखो छो देखो
बहुत मैं छोटा करूंगा मजाक देखो यह होता
है पुट यूजर इन टाइम आउट और यह टाइम आउट
कितने देर के लिए भैया 30 मिनट के लिए
क्लास एंड
तक थैंक यू सर पैसों के कारण 5g फोन अभी
तक लिया नहीं है इसलिए लाइव जवाइन नहीं कर
पाता और वीडियो डाउनलोड करके देख लेता हूं
आप बहुत बढ़िया पढ़ाते हो थैंक यू
पेंटेस्ट विजार्ड ब्रदर थैंक यू सो
मच
धन्यवाद
चलिए ओके तो डिस्टरबेंस को थोड़ा टाटा बाय
कर दिया हमने अब हम यहां पे शुरू कर देते
हैं कहां ते यहां पे तो अब ये जो आपको
रिजल्ट देख रहे हैं अब ये रिजल्ट्स को
देखिए पैरामीटर कौन सा है जिसपे जो
वल्नरेबल है कैट पैरामीटर जो हमने पता
हमने देखा था कैट इक्वल टव पैरामीटर टाइप
एरर बेस्ड कौन सा टाइप है एएल इंजेक्शन का
एरर बेस्ड है टाइटल
मायकल ठीक है 5.6 या इक्वल्स टू मतलब जो
भी है यहां पे ग्रेटर दन 5.6 या इक्वल्स
टू एरर बेस्ड वी आर हैविंग ऑर्डर बाय अ
ग्रुप बाय क्लॉज यहां पे पेलो कैट = 1 एंड
यहां पे सबसेट वगैरह कुछ यूज हो रहा है
फिलहाल के लिए अब जो इंपॉर्टेंट है वो आते
हैं यहां पे यहां पे टाइप जो है एक एरर
बेस्ड पे यहां पे पेलोड कैट = 1 पे यहां
पे माल वर्जन का पता लगाया यहां पे ठीक है
बढ़िया चीज है यहां टाइम बेस ब्लाइंड पे
मा एसक्यूएल का वर्जन का पता लगाया यहां
पे टाइम बेस ब्लाइंड कोरी स्लिप ठीक है
पलट कैट इ 1 पे अच्छी बात है और यहां पे
टाइप यूनियन क्वेरी का पता लगाया यूनियन
क्वेरी टाइप से मा स्कल यूनियन क्वेरी के
लिए 11 कॉलम्स का यहां पे पता लगाया गया
11 कॉलम्स जी हां 11 कॉलम्स का पता लगाया
गया एंड यहां पे पेलो जो है वो ये यूज
किया गया यूनियन ऑल सेलेक्ट जो हम यूज
करते थे नल नल न ननल कॉन कट और ये जो आप
ने देखा था जो इनकोडिंग करके हमने यहां पर
अलग-अलग पहले यूज की हुई थी एंड देन यहां
पर हैश हैश देख रहे हो भैया हैश हैश का
मतलब क्या हुआ बताइए मुझे यहां हैश देखने
को मिल रहा है आपको पेलोड में व्हाट इट
मींस यह किस टाइप का एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन है
इस पैरामीटर में
बताइए हैश देखने को मिल रहा है किस टाइप
का स्कल इंजेक्शन है बताइए
हां ठीक है कमेंट आउट करने के लिए बट किस
टाइप काक इंजेक्शन है यह तो बता दीजिए वाह
ग्रेट ग्रेट बहुत
बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया गुड गुड गुड
गुड गुड पोस्ट बेस्ड अब समझ में आ रहा है
कांसेप्ट क्या होती है समझ में आ रहा ना
कांसेप्ट किसको बोलते हैं छोटी सी चीज
पकड़ में आ गई क्या है
यह
राइट चलिए
बढ़िया यहां पे अब आप यहां पे पेलो डिफाइन
कर सकते हैं और उनको बता सकते हैं रिपोर्ट
के अंदर कि भैया ये पलट था ये पर्टिकुलर
आपका पैरामीटर था एंड हमने यहां पे इस चीज
पे इस तरीके से हंट किया है
दैट्ची है अब देखो यहां पे जब डेटाबेस मिल
चुकी है वी गॉट द डेटाबेस नाउ व्हाट वी
हैव टू डू मैं एंटर कर देता हूं यहां पे
थोड़ा सा अरे यार ये क्या हो रहा
है अब हमें क्या हुआ है डेटाबेस मिल चुका
है वी गॉट द डेटाबेस हियर हमें क्या मिला
हमें डेटाबेस मिल चुका डेटाबेस का नाम था
एक्यू आर्ट वी गॉट द डेटाबेस नेम एज एक्यू
आर्ट अब हमें इसमें क्या करना है अब
हमें डेटाबेस के अंदर क्या होता है टेबल्स
होती हैं सो व्हाट वी हैव टू फाइंड वी हैव
टू फाइंड द टेबल्स अब टेबल्स फाइंड करने
के सारी कमांड को आप सेम रखिए चाहे तो रख
सकते हैं चन सिंपल सा या हान डीबीएस के
जगह पर हाइन हान डीबीएस की जग हाइन हान
टेबल्स लगाना है और टेबल्स जब लगाएंगे तो
आप देखिए यहां पर मैं यहां प हाइन हाइ फन
टेबल्स प ले चलता
हूं यह रहा हाइन एफन टेबल्स तो जब आप
टेबल्स लगाएंगे तो अब यहां पर आप किस
पर्टिकुलर डेटाबेस का का टेबल चाहते हैं
वो डेटाबेस मेंशन करेंगे एंड वो मेंशन आप
हाइन डी से करेंगे डीबीएमएस डेटाबेस टू
इनमेट यानी कि उस पर्टिकुलर डेटा बेस को
इनमेट करके उसके अंदर की टेबल्स फाइंड
करनी है तो हाइन हाइन टेबल्स एंड देन हाइन
डी डेटाबेस के लिए जिसका नाम है एक्यू ए
आटी
एक्यूट बस अब हम एंटर करेंगे एंड लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग देखते हैं क्या होता
है चलिए देखते हैं भैया टेबल्स हमें कुछ
मिलती ही है कि नहीं मिलती
है देखते
हैं देखो अब यह आ गया यह मतलब वो जो
मोटिवेशन नाम का बंदा था सर एक और मजाक
करो ना देखो इसलिए ऐसे लोग कुछ नहीं कर
पाएंगे लाइफ में सच में मोटिवेशन तुम्हारा
नाम जो भी है
भाई तुम्हारा जो भी नाम है तुम कुछ नहीं
कर पाओगे लाइफ में तुम बस यही करते रह
जाओगे स्पैम करते रह जाओगे जिंदगी भर
स्पैम करते रहोगे एक दिन तुम्हारी लाइफ
खुद ही स्पैम हो जाएगी बस यही कहूंगा
ज्यादा नहीं बोलूंगा मैं ठीक है हो गया कर
दिया मजाक अब चलो निकलो अब
भाई हो गया बस हो
गया हो गया मजाक चलिए अब मजाक मजाक हो गया
अब देखिए हमने यहां पे हमें एक्यू आर्ट
व्हाट वी गॉट यहां पे एक्यू आर्ट डेटाबेस
का जब हमने यहां पे क्वेरी किया तो हमें
एक्यू आर्ट डेटाबेस का एक्यू डेटाबेस के
यहां पर टेबल्स मिल कितने टेबल्स है य पर
बताइए
मुझे कितने टेबल्स य कितने टेबल्स मिले
हमें सागर शर्मा ब्लॉग्स थैंक यू सागर
वेलकम टू द फर्स्ट सेशन प्लीज कंप्लीट ल द
सेशन ए टेबल्स हमें मिले टोटल भैया वी गट
ए टेबल्स टट इन टोटल वी गट
टेबल ठीक है टेबल्स कनकन से है आर्टिस्ट
कार्ट्स कैट ची फीचर्ड गेस्ट बुक पिक्चर्स
प्रोडक्ट यूजर्स तो इसमें सबसे
इंटरेस्टिंग टेबल कौन सा है इन सारों में
इंटरेस्टिंग टेबल सबसे कौन सा बताइए मुझे
जो आपको इंटरेस्टिंग लग रहा हो बता
दीजिए यूजर्स क्योंकि इसी में कुछ मिलने
का चांस भी है मुझे जहां तक लग रहा है तो
हमारे पास जो सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग टेबल्स है
वह है यूजर्स ठीक है अब अगर आप भूल ना जाए
तो आप इसका एक लिस्ट बना सकते हैं टेबल्स
और जो भी यूजर्स आपको मिल रहा है ना आप
लिस्ट बना सकते हैं जैसे डेटाबेस
कौन सा मिला हमें एक्यू आट टेबल जिसमें हम
क्वेरी कर रहे हैं वह कौन सा है यूजर्स
ताकि हम बाद में ऐसा ना हो कि भूल जाए फिर
जब हमें रिक्वायरमेंट हो तो पता ही नहीं
चले तो हमने यूजर्स यहां पर लिख लिया
यूजर्स तो चलिए अब हमारा नेक्स्ट जो
टारगेट है यूजर्स नाम के टेबल से कॉलम्स
को फाइंड करना है उसके अंदर कितने कॉलम्स
है बहुत इजी है भैया अब क्या करेंगे क्या
करेंगे यहां पे टेबल्स के जगह पे सिंपल
क्या करेंगे देखते जाइए हाइन हाइ
फन कॉलम्स लगाएंगे लगा
दिया बट अब ये कॉलम्स तो लगा लिया लेकिन
अब कॉलम्स किस टेबल से निकालना है यह
डिफाइन करना बहुत जरूरी है भैया तो हम
यहां पे कॉलम्स जब यूज करेंगे हाइफान
हाइफान कॉलम्स तो ये कौन से टेबल से ये
निकालना है कौन से टेबल को इनमेट करनी है
तो हाइन t यूज करेंगे तो हम यहां बस यहां
पर क्या एंटर करेंगे हाइन टी एंड टेबल का
नाम दे देंगे यू जस ट्स इट बाकी सब सेम ही
रखेंगे हाइन डी जो डेटाबेस से निकालना है
व डेटाबेस तो देंगे ही बस ट्स
इट ट्स इट बस यही तो
है चलिए अब एंटर करते हैं लेट्स सी इफ यू
आर गेटिंग एनी कॉलम्स देखते हम कॉलम्स
मिलते नहीं मिलते पर्टिकुलर यूजर्स नाम की
फोल्डर के अंदर
में लेटस सी
सर क्या रोज का दो से तीन एसकल इंजेक्शन
पॉसिबल है पा से 6 घंटे में ऐसा कुछ नहीं
है ऐसा कुछ गारंटी नहीं होता है कि इस
आपको मिल
जाएगा डिपेंड्स ऑन द टारगेट ऑन द स्कोप जो
भी है टारगेट पर डिपेंड करता है
ब्रदर
देखिए अब यहां पर यह देखो यह देखो यहां पर
अब क्या हुआ हमारे को कॉलम्स मिले किस
फेचिंग कॉलम्स फॉर टेबल यूजर्स इन डेटाबेस
एक्यूआ और हमें यहां पर अब कॉलम्स मिल
चुके हैं भैया कॉलम्स में क्या मिले हैं
नेम है एड्रेस है काट है सीसी ओ क्रेडिट
कार्ड भी है क्या ईमेल है पासवर्ड है फोन
है यू नेम है सब कुछ है देख रहे
हो तो हमें सारी डिटेल्स मिल रही है यहां
जो पर्टिकुलर अंदर में जो कॉलम्स है वो
सारे कॉलम्स मिल गए ये पूरी की पूरी
वेबसाइट को डंप कर रहे हो पूरी की पूरी
वेबसाइट को डंप कर रहे हो तुम
ये दिस इज द डंपिंग
दिस इज कॉल्ड डंपिंग ये पूरा वेबसाइट आप
डंप कर रहे हो भाई इतना तो समझ में आ रहा
है ना कि पूरी वेबसाइट डंप हो रही
है तो एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन से एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन वैसे भी बहुत ही क्रिटिकल एक
क्रिटिकल वनबिल होती है दिस इज अ क्रिटिकल
वनबिल
एसकल इंजेक्शन नॉट नॉट जस्ट लाइक यूजुअल
वनरे बिलिटी जो यूजुअल रिमोट कोड ए क्यूशन
हो गया ये सब हो गया नहीं य क्रिटिकल वल
बिलिटी होती है
भाई ठीक है तो अब हमें क्या करना है
इनको आई स्टार्टेड योर प्लेलिस्ट फ्रॉम
यस्टरडे एंड लव इट मैन थैंक यू सो
मच थैंक यू सो मच सर मैं जा रहा हूं
स्टार्टिंग से सीखने हा ठीक है स्टार्टिंग
से सीखो
वेलकम ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पर हमें क्या
करना है हमें यहां पर डाटा निकालना है
कॉलम्स तो निकाल लिया अब हमें डटा चाहिए
भैया तो अब हमें डटा अब हम डटा कैसे
निकालेंगे सिंपल सा फंडा क्या है हाउ वी
विल फेच द डाटा तो अब डेटा के लिए क्या
करना है सेम कमांड रहेगी आपकी सेम कमांड
रहेगी सेम कमांड रहेगी इस बस यहां कॉलम्स
के जगह पे अब हाइ फन हाइ फन क्या देंगे
बताइए क्या देंगे हाइ फन हाइ फन के बाद
क्या देंगे बताइए जल्दी बताइए जल्दी जल्दी
जल्द बताइए शरद इज सेइंग डंप ठीक है और
बताइए
लोग
बताइए बिल्कुल विल यूज द कमांड डंप हाइन
हाइन डंप तो हमें ड डंप करना है बेसिकली
तो नफन य प डंप लगा दिया अब डंप तो लगा
दिया बट भैया डंप किससे कॉलम से ही तो
करनी है ना तो क्या करेंगे हाइन सी डीबीएम
एस डेटाबेस टेबल कॉलम्स टू इनमेट कौन से
कॉलम्स को नरेट करना है तो हाइन डंप कर
दिया हाइन c और अब कौन-कौन से कॉलम्स को
इनमेट करना है यह भी तो बताओ भाई कौन-कौन
से कॉलम्स को इनमेट करनी है तो हमें इनमेट
करना है नेम एड्रेस यह सारी चीजें तो हमें
इनमेट करना है सीसी सीसी को नरेट कर लेते
हैं ईमेल ईमेल को नरेट कर लेते हैं
पासवर्ड इसको भी नरेट कर लेते हैं बस इतना
ही करते हैं सीसी ईमेल पासवर्ड यू नेम भी
कर लेते हैं यू नेम यूजर नेम होगा यू नेम
कर लेते हैं ठीक है यू नेम सो नाउ वी आर
इनमेट सीसी ईमेल पास यू नेम वेरी वेरी
ओल्ड कंटेंट ओल्ड कंटेंट नहीं है भाई
कंसेप्ट है कांसेप्ट सीखो ओल्डड कंटेंट और
नया कंटेंट क्या होता है ये कांसेप्ट है
तो सीसी ईमेल पास यू
नेम इतना किया
नाउ हाइन टी टेबल यूजर से डी डेटाबेस
एक्यू आर्ट से एंड दैट इट नाउ लेट्स सी
लेट्स प्रेस एंटर लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग
लेट्स
सी चलिए यह काम हो रहा है
अपना काम हो रही
है हाउ मच टाइम आई नीड टू स्पेंड और बाउटी
डिपेंड करता है आपके ऊपर टोटली डेली का
चार पाच घंटे दे पाते हैं तो बेटर है
बेस्ट ऑप्शन है बेस्ट चीज है आपके
लिए ओके इट इज फेचिंग ये देखो फेच किया
यहां पे फेच किया यहां पे फेच में हमें एक
एंट्री मिली है एक एंट्री मिली है एक
क्रेडिट कार्ड की इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है एक
ईमेल आईडी मिली ली है एक पासवर्ड मिला है
टेस्ट और एक यू नेम मिला है टेस्ट सो हमें
यहां पे क्या मिल गया हमें यहां पे रिजल्ट
मिल चुके हैं एंड यहां पे टेबल एकू .
यूजर्स डंप टू सीएसबी फाइल आपके इस लोकेशन
पे ये डाटा डंप हो चुकी है फेस डाटा लॉग
टू टेक्स्ट फाइल ये एक लॉग फाइल है जहां
पे आपका
डाटा जो है वो सेव हो रखा
है ठीक है अंडरस्टूड गाइ समझ में आ गया तो
इस तरीके से आपने यह डंप कर लिया अब यहां
जो डंप हुई है ये चीजें ना यह आपकी प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में डंप हुई है कई बार ये जो डाटा
है आपके इनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में डंप होंगे
जैसे यूजर नेम पासवर्ड या जो भी डटा है ना
कई बार इनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में होंगे तो जब
आपको कोई एनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में डेटा
मिलती है तो उसको आपको डिक्रिप्ट करना
होता है बिना डिक्रिप्ट किए आप उसको यूज
नहीं कर पाएंगे तो यू हैव टू डिक्रिप्ट
दैट डेटा ठीक है डिक्रिप्ट करेंगे देन आप
उसको यूज कर पाएंगे ओके दैट्ची आपका
एसक्यूएल मैप का पूरा एसक्यूएल मैप का
पूरा आपके टेक्निक जो होती है अब हम एक
रियल टारगेट पे हंट करेंगे वी विल गो एंड
वी विल ट्राई टू फाइंड अ रियल टारगेट
क्योंकि रियल टारगेट के लिए आप बहुत
ज्यादा वेट करते हैं भैया तो हम एक रियल
टारगेट पर हंट करेंगे और अलग-अलग ऑप्शंस
लगाएंगे ट्राई करेंगे डेटाबेस फाइंड करने
का वीविल ट्राई अगर मिल जाता है तो मिले
ना मिले दैट इज अ डिफरेंट थिंग बट या
स्टिल वी विल ट्राई ठीक है चलिए रियल
टारगेट प हंट करें रियल टारगेट सर्च करें
गाइस बता दीजिए एक बार सभी पब्लिक साथ में
है रियल टारगेट के लिए पब्लिक पब्लिक
जल्दी बताओ पब्लिक
टर यूज कर लेना यार तुम मेरे से ही क्यों
करा रहे हो सारा आगे बढ़ने दो ना चलिए तो
रियल टारगेट को सर्च करते हैं रियल टारगेट
सर्च करने के बहुत ऑप्शन है बहुत तरीके
हैं कोई सा भी तरीका यूज कर सकते हैं ग
डॉक वगर भी यूज कर सकते हैं कहीं से भी
उठा सकते हैं टारगेट को कहीं से कुछ भी कर
सकते हैं ठीक है जैसे मैं यहां पे कोई भी
टारगेट अगर ले लू
लाइक चलिए एसकल आई पेलोड्स
या एसकल आई डॉक्स मैं ट्राई करता हूं एंटर
यहां पे googlephotos.com
अहमदाबाद यूनिवर्सिटी का देखते हैं
वल्नरेबल है कि नहीं यहां
पे क्या रिजल्ट आता में वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
एनीथिंग
माइट बी वल्नरेबल और नॉट वल्नरेबल कुछ भी
हो सकता है वल्नरेबल हो भी सकता है नहीं
भी हो सकता है तो एक बार इसको टारगेट एक
बार चेक कर लेते हैं क्या जाता है हमारा
मतलब हमारा टारगेट है ना अहमदाबाद
यूनिवर्सिटी को चेक कर लेते हैं चलो या
वैसे तो कोई कुछ हमें एरर नहीं मिल रही है
बट स्टिल वी कैन गिव इट अ ट्राई तो हमें
क्या करना है मै आप अब इतने कमांड डाल रखे
हैं ना भैया तो तो इतना रहने देते हैं
सारा कमांड ऐसे ही रहने देते हैं कुछ
चेंजेज करेंगे हम इसके अंदर तो चलिए पहले
हम यहां पे टारगेट को चेंज कर लेते हैं और
यहां पे ये हान डी वगैरह ये सब हटाना
पड़ेगा आपको पता ही होगा क्योंकि फ्रेश कर
रहे हैं तो हान हान i डीबीएस लगाएंगे हम
ओनली डेटाबेस के लिए एंड यहां पे हम अपना
टारगेट को चेंज कर लेते
हैं लेट्स चेंज द टारगेट टारगेट अब हो
चुका है एटीपीए एएए ड एडी अहमदाबाद
यूनिवर्सिटी
edu.in फलाना डिकाना आईडी = 1 एंड
दैट्ची भी हमने यूज कर लिया है इसके अलावा
आप जो है गाइज कुछ अदर सेशन कुछ अदर चीजें
भी आप यूज़ कर सकते हो नो कास्ट प हमने कर
लिया फ्लश सेशन भी कर लिया हमने ठीक है
यहां पे यहां पे आप कुछ जैसे कि लाइक
रिस्क एंड लेवल का यूज कर सकते हैं जैसा
कि मैंने आपको बताया था यहां पे कहां गई
कंट्रोल एफ हाई फनन
रिस्क
रिस्क यह वाला हान रिस्क रिस्क ऑफ टेस्ट
टू परफॉर्म एंड लेवल ये यूज कर सकते हैं
तो मैं यहां पे हाई फन फन रिस्क इ इक्वल
टू फ कर देता हूं आई थिंक मैक्सिम फाइव ही
है ना रिस्क
का रिस्क का थ्री है लेवल हां हाफ रिस्क इ
3 हाफ लेवल इज इक्वल टू
फ तो हमने लेवल को इंक्रीज कर दिया
मैक्सिमम रिस्क हाफ ल लेवल इ इक्वल टू फव
रिस्क इ इ 3 तो ये हमने एक यूज कर लिया तो
हम रिस्क और लेवल ये दो चीजें हम यूज कर
रहे हैं जस्ट फॉर जस्ट ट्राई वी आर
ट्राइंडर स्क्रिप्ट में मोड सिक्योरिटी
वर्जन स्पेस टू कमेंट कर लिया इसके अलावा
वी कैन यूज आल्सो कॉमा डेलीमिटर
[संगीत]
अ ये यूज कर सकते हैं अलग-अलग मड लाइक टपर
स्क्रिप्ट को यूज कर सकते हैं वी कैन यूज
वी कैन ट्राई आउट एंड यहां पर हमने इतना
कुछ कर दिया डी हो गया र एजेंट हो गया हो
गया थड को कर दिया है बैच कर दिया रिस्क
लेवल फ कर दिया है फ्रेश क्वेरीज कर दी है
फल सेशन कर दिया है एंड और थिंक और कुछ
यहां पर कुछ यूज कर सकते आप लोग बताइए
जल्दी आप लोग बताइए कुछ और इसमें ऑप्शन
यूज कर सकते हैं क्या रम एजेंट को हमने
यूज कर लिया है नो कास्ट को नो कास्ट कर
लिया क्या हमने नो कास्ट को हमने कर ही
लिया है फ्लश सेशन को कर लिया है सब कुछ
कर लिया बताइए मुझे चैट में बताइए मैं देख
रहा हूं चैट आई एम सीइंग द चैट प्लीज लेट
मी नो गाइस आई एम सीइंग द चैट इफ यू कैन
यूज समथिंग
एल्स जल्दी बताओ
दीजिए यहां से देख के बता दीजिए एसक्यूएल
मैप के इससे देख के बता
दीजिए प्रॉक्सी को यूज करेंगे अभी जब अगर
जरूरत होगी तो करेंगे फिलहाल जरूरत तो ऐसा
कुछ खास है नहीं
जब हम नहीं कर पाएंगे ना कुछ रिजल्ट हमें
नहीं मिल पाएंगे तो प्रॉक्सी का यूज ट्राई
कर लेंगे देख लेंगे फिलहाल के लिए
वल्नरेबल अभी फिलहाल मुझे तो नहीं लग रहा
यह पर्टिकुलर टारगेट वल्नरेबल
है बट स्टिल व विल
ट्राई तो रन करते हैं लेट्स
सी इटस स्टार्टिंग
आई थंक कोई वफ तो नहीं है
शायद शायद कोई वफ नहीं है यहां पर आ रहा
है ड टू फॉलो यस पॉसिबल कुछ है
नहीं आईडी पैरामीटर के लिए ट्राई कर रहा य
टू बी डायनेमिक पॉसिबल इंटी जर कास्टिंग
डिटेक्टेड
इसलिए हमने
इंटी जर कास्टिंग डिटेक्ट हुई है इसलिए
हमने यहां पर नो कास्ट यूज भी किया
है बट देखते
हैं नहीं जरूरत नहीं है क्रॉल की जरूरत
नहीं है क्रॉल की अभी तो लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग गाइस होता
क्या है क्या होता है देखते हैं
हो
सो थिंग एल्स कुछ रिजल्ट तो आ जा भाई
थ्रेट्स का यूज कर सकते थे
हम बट हमने किया तो नहीं है बट ठीक है
नेक्स्ट यूज कर नेक्स्ट यूज कर लेंगे
थ्रेड्स का ठीक है अगर अगर यह चीज हो जाती
है जब तक हम कोई और एक टारगेट को देख लेते
हैं सही
बोला लेटस पिक सम अदर टारगेट र न्यूज
डिटेल्स राइस यूनिवर्सिटी कौन सा
यूनिवर्सिटी है भाई अमेरिका कोई
यूनिवर्सिटी है य पर
जलालुद्दीन डिग्री कॉलेज यह कहां की है
भाई जलालुद्दीन डिग्री कॉलेज याय कहां की
है कहां की कॉलेज है य पता नहीं कहां की
है य बैग नखली क किसी और कंट्री की हैय
देखते हैं य वल्नरेबल शायद हो हा चेंज तो
आ रही है इसके अंदर तो वल्नरेबल हो सकती
है यह तो दिस कैन बी वल्नरेबल तो इसको एक
रहने देते हैं यहां पर देख लेते हैं एक
बार दिस इ वल्नरेबल और नॉट
माइट बी बट कोई और भी देखते हैं चलो यहां
पर थो फिल्टर लगाते हैं टूल्स पर चलते हैं
और रिजल्ट पर सॉरी एनी टाइम प करते हैं
पास्ट वीक पास्ट वीक वाले रिजल्ट लाते हैं
य प एंड तब देखते हैं कुछ मिल रहा है क्या
हमें पास्ट वीक में कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ
मिल रहा है
क्या नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथि थ कुछ खास तो
नहीं मिला चलो पास्ट वीक से ना यहां पर
पास्ट मंथ कर देते हैं ए देन देखते हैं
ओके ओके व्ट इ दिस महाज
कंटूटन स मेज
फीड ओके वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग
यहां से तो हमें यहां भी कुछ नहीं मिला
पास्ट वीक
से ये कोई गवर्नमेंट वेबसाइट है आई थिंक
नेशनल डायरेक्टर जनरल ऑफ फॉर एलियंस हैं
एलियंस पुलिसिंग ये क्या है
भाई आईडी इल
टू देखते हैं हालाकि इस पे हम कुछ करेंगे
नहीं लीव इट और भी देख लेते
हैं यहां नहीं है फिल्टर पास्ट मंथ से
पास्ट यर कर देते हैं देखते हैं फिर यहां
पर शायद आ जाए कुछ आपको इंडो चेंबर हा अब
यहां पर आ रहे हैं कुछ पीडीएफ
कॉफी गवर्नमेंट कॉलेज कौन सा य नोखा
गवर्नमेंट कॉलेज तो यह गवर्नमेंट कॉलेज है
तो यहां पर एक बार देख लेते
हैं व आर गेटिंग समथिंग
न नो
चेंजेज थिंग कुछ खास चेंज नहीं आ रहा तो
इट माइट नॉट बी वल्नरेबल
ये क्या है इंडियन इंस्टिट्यूट ऑफ
टेक्नोलॉजी
जयपुर अच्छा जोधपुर मुझे लगा इस जोधपुर
आईआईटी जोधपुर में है मुझे लगा तो कुछ है
नहीं कुछ वैसे तो ओके ओके ओके
मेट्रोपोलिटन मेट्रोपॉलिटन होटल न्यू
दिल्ली क्या है भाई यह मेट्रोपॉलिटन होटल
न्यू दिल्ली न्यू दिल्ली की कोई होटल है
भाई तो इस पर चेक आउट कर लेते हैं क्या है
इसके अंदर है क्या कुछ कुछ रिजल्ट्स में
चेंजेज मिले हैं क्या कुछ पेज
कुछ खास चेंजेज नहीं मिल रहे हैं तो माइट
नॉट बी वल्नरेबल
एक यह है मिनिस्ट्री ऑफ लैंड्स एंड नेचुरल
रिसोर्सेस किसी कंपनी किसी गवर्नमेंट की
है
यह छोड़ छोड़ो गवर्नमेंट वाली चीजों पर
छोड़ देते हैं कोई और देखते हैं
नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग
न नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग व्ट इ दिस यार कोई एक
वेबसाइट है
यह जेमस्टोन
एयू ओके ओके ओके चलो बहुत सारी है य पर
देखते हैं
इ य गट
समथिंग हो तो रहा है बट काफी स्लो रहा है
य कोई बात नहीं होने देते इसको कोई टेंशन
नहीं य चलो कुछ और भी पैरामीटर ले लेते
डॉक्स में कुछ और भी डॉ ले लेते
लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक देखते य
पर गैलरी से रिलेटेड कुछ है क्या हा फोटो
गैलरी यह वाली डॉक ले लेते पॉपुलर डॉक है
स्कूल कॉलेजस वगर की वेबसाइट मिल सकती है
इसमें फोटो गैलरी वाले
में जेम स्टोस इसमें कुछ कीवर्ड वो है
क्या मुझे कुछ दिख तो नहीं रहा
एमरल्ड शप इ ट एमरल्ड ठीक है यहां पर आया
एक पैरामीटर शेप तो यहां पर मैं एक बार
देख लेता
हूं कुछ खास रिजल्ट्स हमें देखने को मिले
नहीं यहां पे तो जस्ट लीव इट
यहां पर थ फूड बेवरेज में कुछ मिला नहीं
है कुछ मिला नहीं है इसमें रिजल्ट मिले तो
ल ट्रा न दिस ब य फोटो गैलरी वाली भी एक
बार देख लेते हैं द साय क्या है कौन सी है
भाई ओके सो य गवर्नमेंट पोस्ट ग्रेजुएट
कॉलेज थाली सेन पूर्वी
गरवाल उत्तराखंड का कोई कॉलेज है वेबसाइट
है इस पर ट्राई कर लेते हैं
अरे य तो गायब हो गया भाई इट्स ल गन यह
वल्नरेबल हो सकता है एल इंजेक्शन से इट
माइट वल्नरेबल तो इसको ट्राई आउट कर लेते
हैं लेटस ट्रा दिस
वन एंड लेट्स ट्राई टू फाइंड समथिंग
समथिंग तो यहां पर कुछ नहीं मिल रहा हम
इसको हम क्लोज कर देते हैं क्विट कर देते
हैं यहां पर हम अपना टारगेट को चेंज करते
हैं वल ट्राई न दिस
यह आ गया यहां पे अब यहां पर आते
हैं कॉलेज की वेबसाइट प कर देखते हैं
देखते हैं यार पले एक टारगेट को कोई एक
टारगेट को ले लेते ये टारगेट हो गया
हमारा डीबीएस यहां पर करना है सब कुछ यहां
प हमने लगा रखा है थ्रेड्स का यूज हमने
नहीं किया था आई रिमेंबर थड हा थ्रेड यूज
किया फ ठीक है अब एंटर करते हैं लेट्स सी
व्ट इंग लेट्स सी देखते हैं यहां पे
कोई ये ये देखो यहां पे डिटेक्टेड दैट द
टारगेट इज प्रोटेक्टेड बाय सम काइंड ऑफ वफ
और आईपीएस तो देख लेते हैं इट इज बायस
बायपास य हो पाता है कि नहीं तो लेट्स
सी यहां आ रहा है पैरामीटर आईडी माइट नॉट
बी इंजेक्टबल तो यह पॉसिबल है माइट नॉट बी
इंजेक्टबल हो सकता है इंजेक्टबल ना भी हो
ठीक है तो इट विल ट्राई आउट अगर इंजेक्टबल
हुआ तो आपको पता चल जाएगा नहीं हुआ तो भी
आपको पता चल जाएगा तो एक तो हमारा ये
टारगेट है इसको हम देते हैं हटा देते हैं
मतलब इन द सेंस लेट्स लुक फॉर सम अदर
टारगेट्स
आल्सो अन्ना यूनिवर्सिटी चेन्नई कोई कुछ
है क्या यहां पे कोई
पैरामीटर ठीक है एक कोई फोटो का वो ओपन कर
लेते हैं ना कुछ
यहां पर कॉलेज है इनुल कॉलेज डट एड आ इनल
कलेज एड
आ तो यहां पर देखते हैं यह भी कॉलेज का है
यहां पर देखते हैं कुछ मिलता है क्या हमें
कुछ रिजल्ट कुछ डिफरेंट न गेटिंग डिफरेंट
कुछ रिजल्ट हम कुछ य कुछ खास मिल नहीं रहा
टनिंग कुछ नहीं है ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है बट जरूरी नहीं है कि
हो जाए बट यहां पर देखो य प यह हो रहा है
य अपना काम कर रहा
है अपीयर्स टू बी एंड बलिन बेस ब्लाइंड र
इंजेक्टबल विथ स्ट्रिंग इ ये इंजेक्टबल हो
सकता है माइट बी इट इज
पॉसिबल इट माइट गट इंजेक्टबल अभी देखो
यहां प यह देखो यहां प बैक टा बेस मा स्कल
हमारा जो टारगेट है वह है द ंग यह जो
कॉलेज है यह है मैं कॉलेज दिखा देता हूं
कौन सा कॉलेज था हमारा
यह गवर्नमेंट पोस्ट ग्रेजुएट कॉलेज थाली
सन यह वल्नरेबल है क्या यार ओ माय गॉड
गाइस
गाइस सो वी
सक्सेसफुली सक्सेसफुली हंटेड ऑन दिस
वेबसाइट एंड हमने एल इंजेक्शन फाइंड किया
है लाइव फाइंड किया है सच में मतलब लाइव
इसमें फाइंड किया है इस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट
में आप यहां देख सकते हो रिा डेटाबेस यह
डेटाबेस आ चुकी है यह देखो भाई इधर देख
लो यह देख लो इधर देख
लो वी गट यर डेटाबेस यहां पर क्या हमें
मिला भैया कौन सा वो यूज हुआ है देख लेते
हैं पैरामीटर आईडी पेलो यहां पे पेलोड
यहां पे आईडी इ इक्वल टू ये पैरामीटर हो
गई आपकी यहां पे एंड वी गट
द डेटाबेस इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा यहां पर एक
डेटाबेस जो है आपका इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा है
जो आपको देख रहे हैं एक डेटाबेस है टेस्ट
और एक है जो एक्चुअल डेटाबेस है 2023 आर
वो डेटाबेस वी गट और जब आप इस वेबसाइट पे
टेस्ट आउट करेंगे एकक इजेक्शन के लिए तो
आपको यहां पर ब्लैंक हो जा जब आप डाल रहे
है ना यहां पे ब्लैंक हो जा रहा है राइट
यह ब्लैंक हो जा रहा है यहां पे आपको
एसक्यूएल की एरर नहीं आ रही है एरियर नहीं
आ रही है ना कि यू हैव एन एरर इन योर
एसक्यूएल सिंटेक्स या फलान डिकाना तो
मैंने आपको पहले भी कांसेप्ट बताया हुआ है
कि जब आप टेस्टिंग करते हैं ना तो पेज में
कोई भी चेंज आ रहा है मतलब नॉर्मली पए पेज
क्या
है यह है बट इसमें किसी भी तरह का चेंज आ
रहा है जब भी आप पैरामीटर्स को चेक कर रहे
हैं डबल कोट लगा के या फॉरवर्ड स्लैश लगा
के या कुछ भी तो आप उसको ट्राई आउट कर
सकते यहां एसल इंजेक्शन केर और हमें क्या
मिल गया है भैया हमें मिल चुकी है य पर
डेटाबेस और यह हो गया कमाल की बात अब हम
इसको ट्राई करते इसके डेटाबेस को थोड़ा सा
अंदर थोड़ा इसके घुसने का तो यहां पर हम
हान डीबीएस के जगह
पर नफन टेबल्स यूज करेंगे एंड हान डी
देंगे डेटाबेस कौन सी डेटाबेस भैया यहां
डेटाबेस का नाम मेंशन कर देंगे यह वाली
डेटाबेस कॉपी
किया पेस्ट किया तो ये वाली डेटाबेस के
लिए हम यहां पर अब हम टेबल्स निकालेंगे
देखते हैं टेबल्स हमें कुछ मिलता है कि
नहीं
रिपोर्ट मेरा वाला रिपोर्ट कर दो खुद से
फाइंड करो रिपोर्ट करो यार मेरा वाला
क्यों रिपोर्ट करोगे करना है तो कर दो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है कर दो कोई टेंशन नहीं है
इतना टेंशन नहीं लेना
है तो इसका मतलब जब ये लिखे कीी माइट नॉट
बी इंजेक्टबल इसका मतलब ये नहीं कि
इंजेक्टबल नहीं है हो भी सकता है जस्ट
ट्रा ट्राई इट
आउट मनी ऑनलाइन तु फिर आ गए फिर मजाक करूं
क्या यही था ना मनी ऑनलाइन उस टाइम प या
कोई और था ठीक है नाउ इट विल ट्राई टू
फाइंड द टेबल्स देखते हैं कई बार होता है
डेटा बेसेस मिल जाएंगे आपके टेबल्स को
डाइव आप शायद ना कर पाए बट मोस्ट ऑफ द
केसेस में ड्राइव ऑफ कर लेते हैं तो देखते
हैं
देखा कर लो कर लो कोई टेंशन नहीं यार
रिपोर्ट कर लो कोई टेंशन नहीं जिंदगी
जिंदगी इतनी टेंशन में नहीं जीनी होती है
जिंदगी इतनी टेंशन में मतया करो छोटी सी
जिंदगी है छोटी सी जिंदगी है क्या क्या
चीजें करनी है उसमें छोटा सा रिपोर्ट लेक
क्या ही टेंशन मस्त रहो अब देखते ना
टेबल्स निकालता है कि
नहीं बड़ी बात यह
है सर एक वेबसाइट है मेरे कॉलेज की
तुम्हारे कॉलेज की तुम ट्राई करो भाई मैं
तो ट्राई नहीं करूंगा तुम्हारे कॉलेज प
तुम ट्राई करो जो करना है तुम खुद ही करो
बट हा याद रखना कभी भी कोई ऑलवेज रिमेंबर
दिस इज अ क्लियर डिस्क्लेमर टू एवरीवन
नेवर एवर यूज दिस एसकल इंजेक्शन टेक्निक
और एनी ऑफ द एल इंजेक्शन टेक्निक्स टू डू
एनीथिंग इलीगल कोई भी इलीगल चीज करने के
लिए आप यह काम नहीं करेंगे याद
रखिएगा देखते हैं कितने टेबल्स निकलते हैं
भाई इसके अंदर मुझे लग रहा है कुछ ज्यादा
ही टेबल्स है पता नहीं क्यों
और मोटिवेशन भाई फिर से जाना है क्या
तुम्हें तो यहां पर टेबल्स निकाल रहा हैय
लेट्स सी इफ इट इ फाइंडिंग टेबल्स
नट या टेबल्स तो निकाल रहा है निकाल रहा
है निकाल रहा है निकाल रहा है टेबल्स गाइस
टेबल्स निकल रहे हैं याद रखिएगा
नहीं नहीं नहीं सर जी ठीक है भाई तो आराम
से रहो यार मस्ती में पढ़ो पढ़ो पढ़ो पो
क्या यार इतनी टेंशन लेते हो तुम
लोग ओ माय गॉड देर आर लॉट ऑफ टेबल्स आई
थिंक यस टेबल्स मिल गए हमें हमें टेबल्स
मिले और टेबल्स में हमें मिला एडमिशन
फॉर्म कैटेगरी नोटिस फोटोस
पोस्ट यूजर्स यूजर्स वाली टेबल मुझे मिल
गई यही तो मुझे मिलना था यही तो मुझे
चाहिए था तो यूजर वाली टेबल्स को भाई
निकालना पड़ेगा कि इसके अंदर क्या
है इसके अंदर के
कॉलम्स कॉलम्स तो हाइन फन
कॉलम्स हाइन टी टेबल्स के नाम के लिए टेबल
जो है वह है
यूजर्स ठीक है भैया टेबल हमने दे दिया
यूजर्स कॉलम्स हमें फाइंड करना है नाउ
लेटस सी इ इट इ फाइंडिंग द कॉलम्स सॉरी
हां कॉलम्स यूजर्स फोल्डर के अंदर टेबल्स
के अंदर कॉलम्स यह निकालता है कि नहीं
देखते
हैं ठीक है भाई मैं बनाऊंगा बिल्कुल
बनाऊंगा मजा आ गया यार
मतलब मिल गई अभी एकदम से मस्त वाली एक
टारगेट अपने को
इसको देखते हैं क्या लग रहा है गाइस
कॉलम्स मिलेंगे कि नहीं हमें यूस के
अंदर हाय आई एम फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान वेलकम टू
इंडिया मिलेगा पीव है यह तो हां बिल्कुल
पीव है बट इनकी बग बाउटी प्रम थोड़ी नाना
होगी यार खुद सोचो ना यह बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम थोड़ी चला रहे
होंगे हां अगर ऐसी वेबसाइट है मिल रही है
आपको तो आप इनको अगर रिपोर्ट करना चाहते
हैं बाय चांस बाय चांस ऐसी वेबसाइट को मत
कीजिएगा कोई मुझे नहीं लगता कोई आपको
रिटर्न कुछ मिलेगा आपको या कोई जवाब भी
मिलेगा मुझे जहां तक लगता है ब स्टिल इफ
यू वांट टू कांटेक्ट अस पर आप इनके
कांटेक्ट अस पर जाके आपको इनको जो भी मेल
आईडी वगर मिल रही है ना आप मेल आईडी वगर
पर रिपोर्ट वगैरह कर सकते हैं य वा ठीक है
तो चलिए अब कॉलम्स देखते
हैं आवाज बहुत स्लो आ रही है आपकी आवाज
स्लो आ रही है क्या
गाइस
गाइस इतना जोर से बोल रहा हूं यार आवाज
स्लो कैसे आ रही
है अरे कॉलम्स देखते कॉलम्स मुझे लगता है
ज्यादा होगा इस इसमें इसमें कॉलम ज्यादा
हो सकते हैं मेरे ख्याल से तो ये निकाल
रहा है कॉलम्स नहीं मिले क्या भाई
अले कॉलम्स तो नहीं
मिले देख लो यहां पर डू यू वांट टू यूज
कॉमन कॉलम
एसिस्टेंसिया इसने क्योंकि हमने यहां पे
हाइफ बैच लगाया हुआ था तो बाय डिफॉल्ट
इसने एन कर दिया इसको हम यस करके चेक आउट
कर सकते थे ठीक है वी कुड हैव चेक्ड आउट द
एटीटीपी एरर कोर्स डिटेक्टेड ड्यूरिंग रन
एसटीटीपी एरर कोस क्या है है 403 फॉर
बिडेन 580 टाइम्स 500 इंटरनल सर्वर 41
टाइम्स ये इंटरनल सर्वर एरर भी आ रही है
भाई ये सर्वर की एरर की वजह से ये चीज हुई
है मोस्ट प्रोबेबली दिस इज बीइंग ड्यू टू
द सर्वर एरर और कोई बात नहीं है जैसे मैं
यहां पे इनके होम पेज पे चलता हूं यहां पे
आ गया यहां पे तो दिस इज मोस्ट ड्यू टू
देयर सर्वर एरर तो हो सकता है कुछ भी हो
सकता है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोई टेंशन
नहीं है तो आप इसको दोबारा ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं चेक आउट कर सकते हैं मैं यहां पे
बैच वाली चीज ना हटा देता हूं ताकि यहां
पर यह पूछे और हम इसको अपने मन से इसको जो
करना है करें ठीक है तो यहां पर हमने बाकी
चीज सही रखी है एंड हमने टाम पर यूज किया
स्पेस टू कमेंट फ्लश सेशन किया
है फ्लस सेशन इसको हटा देते
हैं फ्रेश क्वेरीज इसको भी हटा देते हैं
नॉट रिक्वायर्ड फॉर दिस
रिपीटिंग जो हमारा
रिपीटिंग कमांड है उसके लिए कोई जरूरत
नहीं है ए नाउ
लेट्स टाइम सेकंड लगा दे
क्या हाइन हाई फन टाइम सेक इ 10 रख देते
हैं एंड नाउ लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग चलिए
देखते हैं एक बार फिर से डू यू वांट टू
यूज दोस
यस ड य वांट टू यूज कॉमन देखो आ गया ना ये
पूछ रहा है ना कॉमन कॉलम
एसिस्टेंसिया पे पे तो अब ये आ रहा है
व्हिच कॉलम कॉमन कॉलम्स फाइल डू यू वांट
टू यूज तो एक कॉमन जो है कॉमन कॉलम्स की
एक देखो यहां पे क्या है ना ये कॉलम्स
फाइंड नहीं कर पाया एक्चुअली में क्या हुआ
कि कॉलम फाइंड नहीं कर पाया तो अब ये पूछ
रहा है कि डू यू वांट टू यूज कॉमन कॉलम
एजिस्ट मेंस चेक मतलब ये एक वर्ड लिस्ट का
एक वर्ड लिस्ट का यूज करेगा एक पेलोड
लिस्ट का यूज करेगा यह पता लगाने के लिए
कि भाई ये ये कॉलम्स प्रेजेंट है उसमें कि
नहीं है तो इनका एक ऑलरेडी डिफॉल्ट
वर्डलिस्ट जो है यहां पे मिल यहां पे
ऑलरेडी एसक्यूएल मैप के अंदर है जो कि
कॉमन कॉलम्स t एकटी नाम से तो बोल रहा है
कि किसको यूज़ करना है पहला वाला या कस्टम
आपका खुद का है तो मैं पहला वाला ही यूज़
कर लेता हूं वन लिख के एंटर कर देता हूं
एंड देन ये ट्राई करेगा फाइंड करने का तो
हमें अब आपको अब जो है आपको य वेट करना है
एंड ये अब आपके रिट्राईंग कॉलम्स को
रिट्राईंग जो जो कॉलम्स ये फाइंड करेगा तो
हमारे पास पेलोड यहां पे मैनुअल भी थोड़ा
सा यूज़ हो रहा है मैनुअल अप्रोच तो ये
ऑलरेडी एक लोकेशन है यूएसआर शेयर एसक्यूएल
मैप डाटा के अंदर टेक्स्ट के अंदर टी
एक्सटी के अंदर कॉमन कॉलम टी एक्सटी के
पेलो लेबल है तो ये बोला है या तो आप इसको
यूज कर लीजिए या तो आप कस्टम ऑप्शन चूज
करके टू खुद का कोई अगर पेलोड है आपके पास
कस्टम कॉलम का उसको अपलोड कर यहां पे
मेंशन कर दीजिए उसका पाथ हम उसको यूज कर
लेंगे तो अब यहां पे देखो यह देखो यहां पे
ये कॉलम कॉमन जो है ना ट्राइव भी कर रहा
है देख रहे
हो देखा ट्राइव हो रहा है ना आ रहा है रिा
होके मुझे तो लग रहा है आईडी यूजर नेम
टाइप यूजर आईडी कैटेगरी आईडी पासवर्ड हमें
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड चाहिए यार वो दोनों शायद
ट्राइव हो चुके हैं देखो यूजर नेम पासवर्ड
ट्राइव हो चुका है ट्स अ ग्रेट थिंग ट्स द
ब्यूटी ऑफ एएल मैप बहुत ज्यादा दिमाग आपको
वो नहीं करना है नॉलेज देखो एएल मैप चलाने
की ब्यूटी चलाने में सबसे ज्यादा मजा तभी
और सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग तभी होगी जब आपको
एसकल मैप का वर्किंग पता होगा और बिहाइंड
द सीन जो हो रहा है उसका कांसेप्ट पता
होगा तो फिर करो ना यार एकल में आपको यूज
मजा ही आ जाएगा आपको तो फिर क्या टेंशन है
मजा ही मजा है अभी देख लो यहां पर 2724
आइटम्स टोटल जो पेलोड काउंट है 2724 है इस
पर्टिकुलर टेक्स्ट फाइल में इसमें से इतने
कॉलम्स को यह ट्राई कर चुका है 19 पर हो
चुकी है सारे कॉलम्स को यह ट्राई करेगा
एंड देन आपको रिजल्ट देगा थोड़ा टाइम
लगेगा वेट कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं वेट का
फल हमेशा स्वीट
स्वीट तब तक कुछ आपके कमेंट्स देख लेते
हैं सर मैं
सर मैं रोज 12 घंटे करता हूं बग बाउंडी
कैसे तीन महीने में सक्सेसफुल हो सकता हूं
मतलब 10 के मंथ में नि 10 के मंथ में
निकाल सकता हूं ्र मंथ्स में कुछ नहीं
निकाल सकते तुम एक रुपया तुम नहीं निकाल
सकते लिख के रख लो पहले से सोच रखा है तीन
महीने में 10000 निकाल लूंगा कहां से होगा
कुछ नहीं होगा सीखो यार सीखो सीखो लर्निंग
पर ध्यान दो स्किल्स पर ध्यान दो पैसे
वैसे सब आते रहेंगे ऑटोमेटिक पहले सोच
लोगे कि भैया मैं तीन महीने में एक्सपर्ट
होक तीन महीने में 10000 निकाल लूंगा यह
कर लूंगा कुछ नहीं कर
पाओगे फोकस न लर्निंग टाइम और य सब म देखो
अपने बाउंट लगेगी भाई तुम्हारी मनी ऑनलाइन
नाम भी मनी ऑनलाइन रखा
है सेम कमांड आयुष गुप्ता यूज करी है क्या
कुछ ना कुछ तो गड़बड़ होगी एक बार देखो
कुछ शायद मे भी कुछ प्रॉब्लम हो
अब बढ़िया से समझ आ रहा है स्कल मैना आ
रहा है ना मजा हां यही तो बात है यार मैं
समझाऊं और तुम्हें समझ ना आए तो फिर मेरा
समझाने का क्या मतलब रह गया और मेरी
क्लासेस का क्या मतलब रह गया और मेरी
क्लासेस मैं क्लास ले रहा हूं इसका क्या
मतलब रह गया क्लासेस तो बहुत लोग बहुत तरह
से लेते हैं यार बट मैं क्लास ले रहा हूं
तो तुम्हें समझ आना चाहिए नहीं आया तो फिर
मेरा वेस्ट हो गया फिर वो क्लास
लेना लिंक में डबल कोट और
फॉर स्लश बैक स्लश यूज करने पर 404 आ रहा
है वेबसाइट का पेज सो दिस वेबसाइट रेबल
नॉट हां हां नहीं 404 तो मतलब है ही नहीं
यार 404 का मतलब तो अवेलेबल ही नहीं है
क्या बोल रहे हो
यार एसकल मैप एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन मैनुअली
करना दोनों यूज कर सकते हो कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है मैनुअली में आपको बहुत सारा चीज
जो है करने में बहुत टाइम लग जाएगा टाइम
टेकिंग है बग बाउटी में आप मैनुअल करोगे
तो आप उतना टाइम कहां से दोगे यह भी तो
सोचना है उतना टाइम दोगे तब तक दूसरा कोई
निकाल
तो मैनुअल इज ऑलवेज बेटर बट स्टिल टाइम
सेविंग के लिए और उसको बचाने के लिए टाइम
को आपको ऑटोमेटिक करना पड़ता है करना
चाहिए मेरे खल से ठीक है तो हमें यहां पर
जो कॉलम्स मिले अभी मैनुअल अप्रोच से वो
मिले थ्रेड्स आईडी यूजर नेम टाइप यूजर
आईडी कटेगरी आईडी पासवर्ड चलिए यह कॉलम्स
निकाल रहे हैं तब तक हम यहां पर आ जाते
हैं तब तक मैं यहां पर इसको निकालने देते
हैं इसको चलने देते हैं
मैं यहां पर आ जाता हूं आप सबको फिर से एक
बार बता देता हूं य हमारी पेज है लिंकन
डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी हमारी कंपनी की
पेज है 6000 लोगों ने अभी तक फॉलो किया है
आप भी वन ऑफ द फॉलोअर्स बन जाइए जो भी
पोस्ट आते हैं इसको ध्यान से पोस्ट को
पढ़ा कीजिए बहुत सारी अपडेट्स एंड बहुत सी
चीज आपको यहीं पर मिलेंगी यह हमारा एक नया
एक वेंचर बोल सकते हैं बा डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी द इंफोसेक डायरी जो कि एक
चैप्टर स्टूडेंट कॉलेज चैप्टर स्टार्ट हो
रहा है जो बहुत जल्द धमाका ने वाला है
ऑफलाइन मार्केट में यह हमारी पेज है ्र पर
टीम डिक्स यह मैं हूं नितेश सिंह हैकर
चाहे तो आप फॉलो कर सकते हैं यह मेरी मतलब
पेज है ा की यह हमारी वेबसाइट है एंड ट्स
इट यह हमारा लाइव सेशन है जो चल रहा
है फुल मोटिवेशन क्या बात
है गायब हो रहे हैं कुछ अगर तो हो सकता है
तब पॉसिबल है कि वल्नरेबल
हां रिपोर्ट राइटिंग में वीडियो आएगी
टेंशन गायब हो रहा है तो पॉसिबल है कि हां
भैया कितने हो गए भाई यहां पर 72 पर हो
चुके हैं बहुत सारा हो चुका है इट्स ग्रेट
लेटस ट
ंग
देखा ऐसे थोड़ा सा दिमाग लगाना पड़ेगा भाई
कई बार तो जो हमने बैच ऑप्शन लगा या अच्छा
यह मुझे बताओ चैट में हाइन न बैच जो ऑप्शन
है वो सही है या गलत है यूज करना चाहिए कि
नहीं करना चाहिए क्या लग रहा है आपको हान
फन बैच बताइए रियल टारगेट्स पर जब आप हंट
कर रहे हैं तो हान फन बैच ऑप्शन लगाना
चाहिए कि नहीं लगाना
चाहिए जल्दी जल्दी टेल मी गाइस जल्दी
बताइए
करना चाहिए बैच हाफ बैच यूज करोगे ना तो
उससे यह होगा कि एल मैप टूल तुमसे कुछ
इनपुट नहीं मांगेगा अपना डिफॉल्ट ऑप्शन
देता जाएगा और वही हमने बैच यूज किया था
इसके पहले तो यह जो कॉमन कॉलम
एसिस्टेंसिया
कर रहा था जनरली जब आप प्रोडक्शन में काम
मतलब आप जब रियल टारगेट प काम कर रहे हैं
डोंट यूज द नफन बैच ऑप्शन और मैनुअली आप
इनपुट्स दीजिए अपने अकॉर्डिंग जो भी
इनपुट्स मांगा जा रहा है उसको मैनुअली
दीजिए ठीक
है हां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल चलिए 94
पर हो चुका है ऑलमोस्ट वीी आर डन विद द
रिट्रीव ऑफ द कॉलम्स तो बेसिकली हमें जो
कॉलम्स मिले हैं वो 1 दोती च पा 6 कॉलम
मिले हैं इसके अंदर में ठीक
है देखते हैं छ कॉलम्स मिले
हमें हा
जी चलिए तो छ कॉलम्स आ चुके य पर छ कॉलम्स
यह देखिए यहां पर क्या ही बात
है क्या बात है आ चुके ये बड़ा मजा आ रहा
है देख के
बड़ा मजा आया मुझे यह देख तो मुझे मिल गई
डेट मिल गई न्यूमेरिक है टाइप मिल गई नॉन
न्यूमेरिक है कैटेगरी आईडी आईडी मिल गई
पासवर्ड मिल गया यूजर आईडी यूजर नेम हो
गया चलिए अब मुझे डंप करना है तो मैं एक
बार डंप करते हूं डंप करता हूं देखते हैं
ट्राई करके डंप होता है कि नहीं भाई
डंपिंग में ना कोई प्रॉब्लम आ जाए क्या ही
कर सकते हैं तो कॉलम्स हान कॉलम्स के जगह
पर हान डीयू एम प डंप कर देते हैं हाइन सी
कॉलम्स कौन ककन से कॉलम्स करने भैया तो
हमें करना है आईडी
आईडी करनी
है आईडी नहीं करनी या पासवर्ड करना
है कॉमा यूजर अंडरस्कोर आईडी करनी है कॉमा
यूजर नेम करना
है यूजर नेम यह करना है बस और तो कुछ
चाहिए नहीं पासवर्ड यूजर आईडी यूजर नेम और
कुछ भी नहीं चाहिए हान डी टेबल है यह हो
गया यह हो गया सब डम लेट्स
सी ड यू वांट टू यूज दोस
यस अरे हमने यह क्या फ्लश वाला कर लिया था
क्या नहीं नहीं किया यस डम कर रहा है ये
देखते हैं लेट्स
सी देखते हैं टबल क्या होता है
हमारा आई थिंक देर आर पासवर्ड्स बट दोज आर
एनक्रिप्टेड मेरे ख्याल से देख लेते हैं
या वी आर गेटिंग द डाटा एक्चुअल डेटा वी
आर गेटिंग द डटा ये अच्छी बात है वी आर
गेटिंग द
डेटा ट्स ग्रेट गाइस ट्स ग्रेट जब आपको
एनक्रिप्टेड कोई पासवर्ड मिले तो आप उसको
डिक्रिप्ट करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं
क्रैक करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं डू यू
वांट टू स्टोर हैसे टू अ टेंपररी फाइल फॉर
इवेंचर फदर प्रोसेसिंग विथ अदर टूल्स हैश
को अगर कोई और आप टूल एक लाइक टेंपररी
फाइल में डालना चाहते हैं जैसे आप
ने अगर हैश को यहां पे ये पूछ रहा है कि
एक टेंपररी फाइल में डालना चाहते हैं सशस
को ताकि आप फर्द जॉन जॉन द रिपर या हैश कट
का यूज करके पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग यूज कर कर
सके ऐसा कुछ तो मैं यहां पे फिलहाल नो
करता हूं मुझे नहीं चाहिए मैंने नो डू यू
वांट टू क्रैक देम वाय डिक्शनरी बेस्ड
अटैक अब ये बोल र है कि आप क्रैक भी करना
चाहते हैं क्या तो क्रैक कर लीजिए ना वाई
यस क्रैक करना है मुझे तो यहां पे आ रहा
है डिफॉल्ट डिक्शनरी फाइल तो मैं डिफॉल्ट
डिक्शनरी फाइल ही यूज कर लेता हूं यस ड यू
वांट टू यूज कॉमन पासवर्ड सफिक्स स्लो तो
मुझे चाहिए नो मुझे नहीं चाहिए अब ये
ट्राई कर रहा है
पासवर्ड क्रैक करने
का
देखो
क्रैकिंग कर रहे हैं
यह हालाकि हम इसको स्किप भी कर सकते थे
अगर आपको नहीं करना तो क्रैकिंग मत कीजिए
आपको डायरेक्ट डाटा मिल
जाएगी ठीक है
ठीक है भैया ये आ गई मान लो चलो ठीक है हो
गया नो क्लियर टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड फॉर्म कोई
क्लियर टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड इसको नहीं मिला
मतलब क्रैक बेसिकली नहीं हुआ जो भी है
यहां प दो चीजें मिली है एक यूजर नेम
एडमिन मिला है एक यूजर नेम यह एडमिन है
चलो यूजर आईडी अलग अलग है और य ये पासवर्ड
मिले बेसिकली ये पासवर्ड जो है दोनों के
सेम है आप देख सकते हैं हैश दोनों के हैश
है ना बिल्कुल सेम है यानी यूजर नेम एडमिन
है एंड पासवर्ड आपका यह है गट इट तो नाउ
यह जो पासवर्ड
है कॉपी किया हमने हमने कॉपी किया यह शश
जो हैश इसको हम आईडेंटिफाई करने की कोशिश
करते हैं तो
हैश आइडेंटिफिकेशन
बोल रहा ही
ये ओके दिस इज कॉल्ड पॉसिबल एल्स md5 तो
हम इसको क्रैक करने की कोशिश करते हैं इफ
वी कैन डू
समथिंग
अ इसको क्रैक करने की कोशिश करते हैं कक
station.in से तो हमने यहां पे ये डाल
दिया एंड लेट्स सी इफ इट इज क्रैके बल र
नॉट देखते हैं क्रैके बल है कि नहीं है
क्रैक होता है कि नहीं है
अ नॉट फाउंड
नॉट फाउंड आ रहा है नॉट फाउंड आ रहा है
ब्रूट फोर्स कर लेना काफी टाइम लग जाएगा
फिर उसमें पूरा पलट का लिस्ट मुझे डालना
पड़ेगा फिर फिर ट्राई करना पड़ेगा यार
बहुत बहुत टाइम लग जाएगा तो वैसे आप लोग
ऑनलाइन इसको ब्रूट फोर्स कर लीजिएगा या तो
आप ब्रूट फोर्स कर लीजिएगा बब शूट का भी
आप यूज कर सकते हैं अगर आप चाहे तो या तो
आप काली से भी कर सकते हैं डायरेक्टली आप
कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक है
या फिर आप हैश कट वगैरह का यूज कर सकते
हैं इसको क्रैक करने के लिए ठीक है यू कैन
इवन यूज द हैश कट एंड ऑल ये हैश है बस एक
उसको यूज कर सकते हैं तो ऑनलाइन एमडी फ
डिक्रिप्ट ठीक है कोई सा भी टूल यूज कर
लीजिए क्या जाता है देख लीजिए अरवा आप
थोड़ा सा कर लीजिएगा ट्राई ठीक है य पर
डिक्रिप्टर आ जाते हैं ले गो
्र डिक्रिप्ट आ गए एडी य हमने डाला कप
करते लेट इट कैन डिक्रिप्ट और नट कॉमन
होगा तो हो जाएगा नहीं होगा तो फिर आपको
बट फोस करना पड़ेगा ठीक है य जाते हैं
यने
डाला बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
यहां हमने
डाला डिक्रिप्ट करते
हैं नहीं यह हैश डेटाबेस में नहीं है इनके
तो नहीं होगा कुछ खास कॉमन पासवर्ड कॉमन
पासवर्ड नहीं होगा ज्यादा मे बी ट्स वा नो
रिजल्ट कोई डेटाबेस में है नहीं य प कुड
नॉट बी
न य सेटिंग टू ड न्यू कक्टर सेट र इक्रीज
मैस टू ट्रायल काउंट तो अब यहां पर गाइस
थोड़ा सा लाइक चेंज करना पड़ेगा अगर आपको
चेंज करना है तो यू कैन जस्ट चेंज इट आउट
एंड देन यू कैन ट्राई ठीक है कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है तो आप अलग अलग क्रैकिंग जो मेथड
है उसको यूज कर सकते हैं एंड ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं इसको क्रक करने का ठीक
है नहीं होता लाइक आई ये खुद में ही
डिफरेंट चीज है बिल्कुल ललित एब्सलूट फाइन
यू आर सेइंग एब्सलूट करेक्ट ठीक है तो
बेसिकली हमें डेटाबेस यहां मिल चुकी है
एंड हमें यहां पे जो डेटाबेस कहां गई भाई
डेटाबेस यहां हमें डेटाबेस मिल चुकी है यू
गॉट द यूजर नेम पासवर्ड अब यहां पे आपका
काम है इसको क्रैक करना आप इसको क्रैक कर
सकते हैं अलग-अलग टेक्निक्स जो है उसका
यूज करके यू कैन यूज द पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग
टूल्स हैश कड का यूज़ कर लीजिए जॉन द रीपर
यूज कर लीजिए ऑनलाइन क्रैकिंग टूल्स यूज
कर लीजिए व्हाट एवर जो भी है यूज कीजिए आप
सबको पता ही होगा एंड इसको क्रैक कर सकते
हैं ठीक है रही बात कि अब इतना कुछ मिलने
के बाद वी फाउंड एवरीथिंग हमें डेटाबेस
मिल गया टेबल मिल गई कॉलम मिल गया हमें
एक्चुअल डटा मिल गया व सक्सेसफुली यहां पे
एक हमें वल्नरेबल वेबसाइट मिल गई अब ऐसे
आप मल्टीपल थाउजेंड्स ऑफ रेबल वेबसाइट्स
निकाल सकते हैं लबल पैरामीटर्स निकाल सकते
हैं एल मैप का यूज कर सकते हैं आप बब सूट
का यूज करके पूरी वेबसाइट को क्रॉल करके
अलग-अलग पैरामीटर्स निकाल के हर एक
पैरामीटर पे ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं टेस्ट
आउट कर सकते हैं फॉर एल इंजेक्शन ठीक है
पहली चीज देन आप एक चीज मैं हमेशा बताऊंगा
एक चीज हमेशा मैं बोलूंगा एट द एंड एट द
एंड क्या बोलूंगा मैं आपसे मैं आपसे बोलू
यहां पर एक बड़ा सा डिस्क्रिप्शन
दूंगा डिस्क्लेमर डिस्क्लेमर दूंगा
मैं नेवर यूज दज टेक्निक्स
फॉर इलीगल
पर्पस इट मे कॉज प्रॉब्लम्स
लीगल प्रॉब्लम्स
टू
यू डि फोनिक्स और
आय
नेवर
इंस्टिगेट एनी वन
टू वायलेट एनी टर्म्स एंड कंडीशंस
ऑफ यट
और नेवर इनकरेज
इलीगल
एक्टिविटी एनी इल्लीगल
एक्टिविटी यू आर
सोलली रिस्पांसिबल फॉर ऑल योर
एक्ट्स प्लीज यूज दज टेक्निक्स टू लर्न द
कांसेप्ट टू लर्न द कांसेप्ट फॉर योर
एकेडमिक यूज ओनली
एंड फॉलो द
लॉ एंड रेगुलेशंस
इन
योर
कंट्री या
रीजन ठीक है भैया टस ट इना बोलगा यह
पर्टिकुलर डिस्क्लेमर है कभी भी इस
टेक्निक का यूज लील परपस नहीं करना है
लर्निंग परपस से करना है यूज दिस
क्लास ओनली फॉर एजुकेशनल
वैल्यूज
थैंक्स ठीक है बस ये एक डिस्क्लेमर है
अच्छा
सा प्लीज इसको फॉलो
कीजिएगा थैंक यू सो मच सर यू आर पुटिंग सो
मच एफर्ट एंड टाइम फॉर टीचिंग अस बग बाउंट
नो वन कैन डू दिस फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट थैंक यू
सो मच एडस ऑफ टू यू थैंक यू निखिल थैंक यू
थैंक यू सो मच फॉर योर वर्ड्स अच्छा लगता
है जब आप एप्रिशिया जब आपको लगता है कि
मैं अच्छा कर रहा हूं एंड ऐसा ही आपके लिए
लेते आता रहूंगा मैं ऐसी जो क्लासेस है
वीडियोस है आती
रहेंगी ठीक है बस एक्सपेक्ट करता हूं आपके
सपोर्ट की आप यहां लाइव में आइए आप यहां
पे खुद को प्रेजेंट रखिए यह मैं एक्सपेक्ट
करता हूं आप सबसे इससे ज्यादा तो मैं कुछ
नहीं बोलूंगा और वीडियोस को शेयर कीजिए
अपने दोस्तों के बीच जितने भी आपके दोस्त
हैं जितने भी आपके कॉलीग हैं जितने भी
आपके बैचमेट्स हैं स्कूल मेट्स हैं
क्लासमेट्स हैं फ्रेंड्स हैं जो बग
बाउंटीज में आना चाहते हैं साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में आना चाहते हैं उनको शेयर
कीजिए ये वीडियोस ताकि हमें सपोर्ट मिले
इनकरेजमेंट मिले और भी लोग ज्यादा हमारे
डिफ्रॉक फैमिली से जुड़े और भी ज्यादा
डिफन स्टस हमारे साथ जुड़े बस गाइस तो आज
की क्लास के लिए बस इतना
ही ठीक है बस आज के क्लास के लिए फिलहाल
इतना ही एंड मिलते हैं जल्दी नेक्स्ट
क्लास में एक नए टॉपिक के साथ एकस
रिक्वेस्ट इस पार्ट एसएल इंजेक्शन पार्ट
थ्री के पहले पार्ट वन पार्ट टू जरूर
कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा फिर इसको देखिएगा
नेक्स्ट जो भी लेबिलिटी या जो भी क्लास
होगी मैं आपको बता दूंगा आपको जो चैनल है
ओके पार्ट फोर नहीं आएगा भाई यार यहां
लिखा हुआ है एल इंजेक्शन फाइनल पार्ट थ्री
खत्म हो गया एल इंजेक्शन आपका ट्स
इट तो मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट क्लास में अगर आपका सपोर्ट ऐसे ही
रहा तो अच्छी बात है अगर रहा तो बढ़िया है
थैंक यू सो मच गुड
नाइट एंड ऑल द वेरी बेस्ट